e
e e
time being 10:02 we'll get started with
our
Department of Revenue update today sorry
welcome Dr
up good morning good morning Mr chair
members of the committee Lindsay step
commit commissioner at the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration
happy to see you again this time we're
going to talk Revenue
estimates sounds good we're looking
forward to
it you may be okay so you should have a
copy of a presentation in front of you
blue and white maybe we should make it
green and white for money I don't know
change it up next year
maybe okay so what we're going to talk
about today is kind of three things
we're going to talk about where we think
revenues for fiscal year 25 the current
fiscal year that we're in where revenues
are going to end up at the end of June
at the end of the fiscal
year then we're going to talk about a
growth rate from 25 to 26 and then a
growth rate from 26 to
27 so what you see on the first page is
these are
the
scenarios that we run at Dr in order to
come up with options for where fiscal
year
25 is going to end because that's going
to serve as our base for the growth
rates for 26 and 27 so there's five
different scenarios that we look at
first is plan what was the plan for that
tax
type second is sustaining percent versus
plan so we look at at the first seven
months of the fiscal year and we look at
how that's performing compared to plan
and we apply that same percentage to the
remaining months so if through the first
seven months of the year we're 10% ahead
of plan we're just going to assume that
we'll stay 10% ahead of plan for the
rest of the
year the third scenario is the same
thing except we're comparing to Prior
year so we take actuals for the first
seven months and then we look at how
we're doing compared to Prior year if
we're 5% ahead of Prior year we're going
to assume we'll remain 5% ahead of Prior
year for the rest of fiscal year
25 the fourth scenario is the first
seven months of the year with just plan
for the
remainder and then the last scenario is
the first seven months of the year with
prior year actuals for the last five so
we run these five scenarios we update
them at the end of every month so once
we have actual data we'll update it and
then we select a high and a low based on
these scenarios and those are the
options that are going to be presented
to you that's how we come up with a
range for fiscal year 25 I will say
though that the options that we select
for the high and the low are those that
we believe to be reasonable so if for
instance tobacco tax we are far below
plan we're not going to show you the
plan scenario as an option because we
don't believe that that's achievable in
fiscal year 25 so it's not just running
five scenarios and showing you the
absolute High and the absolute low it's
us looking at those those scenarios and
making an educated decision on what we
believe to be a reasonable High and a
reasonable low so we kind of try to take
out the
noise so that's what we do for 25 and
then we just talk growth rates for 26 27
Chris works his magic and applies those
growth rates in your worksheet and way
you
go okay so on page two we're going to do
the heavy lifting first we're going to
start with business
taxes so fiscal year to date business
taxes are 110.3 million or 18.2% below
plan and we're
102.9 million or
17.2% below prior year
things to consider when you're
estimating business tax revenue first is
e economic growth with the resetting of
estimated payments we've talked about
this
before the there is underlying growth in
the economy we are seeing that but we've
seen a reduction in our estimated
payments of businesses have as
businesses have right sized their
estimated payments kind of coming out of
the pandemic and the tremendous growth
that we we saw on corporate profits so
there is growth here but you're looking
below plan and you're you're below prior
year partially due to this resetting of
estimated
payments also things to think about
supply chain constraints disruptions
Imports in factories potential tariffs
or sanctions that's very much an unknown
I think at this
point uh we do have a low unemployment
rate which is good for the economy and
then any impact on interest rate changes
um to the economy as
well so what you see in the blue section
in the middle of the page is a range for
25 of 1 bli 29.5 million to 1
b12.3
million then you see a growth range for
26 between 3 to 8% that would be applied
to
25 and then you see a growth range for
27 again of 3 to 8% and that would be
applied to
26 so for fiscal year 25 your range the
low
range assumes actual revenue for the
first seven months of the year and
assumes that our percent versus plan
18.2% below plan would remain for the
remaining five months of the year so
that revenues just continue on the trend
that they're on from the first seven
months
the high assumes that we take the seven
months of actuals and then the remaining
five months are actual revenue from last
year from fiscal year 24 and essentially
what this high does is assumes that the
decline in the estimated payments that
we've been seeing
stops and that revenue is more
consistent with the prior year so that
means 25 estimates which we just start
to receive in April and we'll receive
again in June calendar year 25 estimates
are consistent with calendar year 24 and
we don't continue to see that decline
from 24 estimates that we saw from 23 so
the resetting of e of estimates kind of
has happened and we're just going to
kind of continue
on with fiso year 24 or excuse me with
how calendar year
24 behaved excuse me can I ask a
question sure
um so in the previous slide you you
listed five different ways that um
revenues uh could be estimated so when
you when you on this chart now when you
give the high and low which one is your
which method are you using so you'll see
that in the little sub bullet Below in
um the kind of open bullet it said
assumes actual revenue for the first
seven months of the year plus sustaining
percent versus plan okay for the last
five
and then for the high this is actual
revenue for the first seven months with
prior year revenue for the last five so
again it's it's showing you the two high
and low options we believe to be
reasonable yeah okay thank you yes
repres
elme thank you
so
on what the way we we've been doing it
doesn't seem to pay much attention to
the possibility of
decline continuing and the decline
continuing is the low estimate that
assumes that the
18% versus plan continues for the
remainder of the
Year FY 25 the last five
months uh isn't that when we were
seeing well we were yeah we were seeing
the the decline from a number of
different factors we don't know how
important one of them versus the other
one is yet though um so this assumes
have you got
uh done any
analysis um lately of how much of the
decline last year was due to to just um
changing their estimates based on oh oh
we've been keeping 300% of
our of our
uh taxes to
come uh that we don't need to keep in
the
treasury so we
can't
isolate individual or we can't isolate
the impact of Chang in estimated
payments because of the CCO cap and the
need need to now refund any credit carry
over over 500% versus a change in
Behavior because businesses now feel
more confident in what their liability
is going to be so I can't tell you what
part of the reduction in estimates is
due to one or the other I can tell you
how much we refunded due to the CCO cap
um but I can't necessarily break down
the change in the behavior of the
estimates because I don't have any
information to do that because as we've
talked about an estimate is one number
on a form with very little
information so that being
said I think there's two bits of
information that I can provide
the
first is that
approximately just under $72 million in
fiscal year 24 was refunded due to the
CCO
cap year to date for fiscal year
25 were at 41
1.7 with respect
to with respect
to changes
in liability of
taxpayers versus the change in their
behavior relative to estimates again I
can't isolate
necessarily I can't
isolate that specifically in the
estimates but I can do a comparison
between how taxpayers have made their
estimated payments as a comparison to
how their liability has
changed and so
from tax year 2020 to
2021 liability for taxpayers increased
by
32% their estimated
payments increase by
40% from tax year 21 to
22 their liability increased by
1% but their estimated payments
increased by
46% so that's the behavior that we're
talking about where there has been a
behavior among taxpayers to increase
their estimated payments in excess of
their liability we saw a similar Trend
happen from 2016 to 2017 when the tax
cut and jobs act went into effect and
taxpayers were uncertain about their
estimate uncertain about their liability
they sent SE they had a 75% increase in
their estimates so when taxpayers aren't
sure many just want to make sure they're
covered and so they'll increase their
estimated payments it takes a couple
years for them to then adjust the
estimated payments when the liability
hasn't risen by the same
percent so the interesting thing here
and we won't know this until after March
15 when tax returns come in then you can
start looking at the liability and is a
liability correct down as well or is
that about the same and a lot of this is
estimates correct so that will will
start to have information in March um in
April as returns are filed the picture
won't be totally clear until we get
those returns that are filed on
extension in the fall and do you have
anyone filing returns now because people
who are on um fiscal years do you have
any of them filing such that you can
compare that so we did look at what has
happened from fiscal year 20 or excuse
me tax year 22 to tax year 23 but even
that is incomplete at this point so it
looks like the liability is down but
it's not a full year and some of those
fiscal filers tend to be um our larger
taxpayers so it is not a full picture
yet but yeah we're kind of constantly
tracking and waiting for those returns
to come in and we we have to make our
decisions prior to March 15
unfortunately you do y but um but we
have a crystal ball obviously
yes um yes
representative thank you Mr chairman uh
just a quick question uh commissioner I
think those numbers are really important
and and I'm wondering if you could make
sure that you provide the committee with
with those numbers in terms of the
difference between liability and and um
and
also the the estimated numbers pay I'm I
I can't do the math in my head but I was
trying to it it seemed like that that
seven-month figure was consistent
with you know potentially in terms of
percent percentage was consistent with
what a full year should produce but um
it'd be helpful to Havey to thank you
representative om yeah thank you I have
a question on economic growth versus tax
growth and the basis for my question is
a recent kinger letter I got talking
about economic growth in the total
country uh they said the growth is 2.8%
last year and declining at 2.4% this
year and we're forecasting 8 % uh tax
growth here in New Hampshire can you
comment on the correlation between the
tax growth and the economic growth here
in New Hampshire sure so I think the
easiest way to discuss that is just to
equate economic growth to GDP right
change in gross domestic product so
we've looked over the years to see
whether and how strong a correlation
might be between GDP and the change in
the tax revenue in New Hampshire for the
business business taxes and I think
there's a few things that make it so
that there's not a direct correlation
one is the timing so when you're talking
about um the timing of growth in the
economy because of how taxes are
ultimately reported up to almost a year
after the tax year closes we don't
always have that timely information to
make that direct
correlation second there are things I
think that make New Hampshire I don't
want to say necessarily unique but we've
talked about the fact that we have a
variety of
Industries um within New Hampshire we're
not heavily reliant on any one or two
industries but that the makeup of our
Industries might be different than the
general economy that is referenced
within
GDP um we might have more manufacturing
or l manufacturing more healthare less
healthare different technology companies
and so the makeup of we're not just an
exact subset of the national
economy um so I think that creates a
difference as
well so now you said there in answering
that question there's a delay between um
GDP and tax um filings which makes sense
is there a way to compare GDP would I
mean knowing that it's skewed GDP with
the tax return it's probably like more
like six month I don't know is it a year
you said a year later but it's it's
tough because of that the estimates are
filed somewhat timely across the tax
year but they only need to be
essentially equal to the prior Year's
liability in order to avoid any
penalties and if you have a credit on
file which we know many taxpayers do
then that gives you some more leeway as
well and
so it's hard to get the whole picture
and what we really need is that
information off of the tax return to see
where various line items have
changed to make the picture complete and
then that is so delayed yeah okay that
makes
sense okay seeing no more questions okay
continue so we come up with the range
for fiscal year 25
and then the growth rate
from 26 and 27 you'll see it's 3 to 8%
in both years
and that's based on um taxpayers kind of
finishing their adjustment to their
estimated payments the estimated
payments have now been kind of right
sized if you will in fiscal year
24 um and the first half of 25 and so
now we go into more of um a true
reflection of estimates to what's
happening in the
economy um and then in
27 this you know kind of is just the
general growth that you would see in the
business profits and business Enterprise
tax um from the slides from my prior
presentations business taxes do
fluctuate quite a bit from year to year
um but when you remove the noise you
remove the years where there's a large
growth or a large decline 3 to 8% is
kind of the
more classic growth um that you would
see in the taxes um from year to year so
I am forecasting an increase it's a bit
of a wider range um just because of
the uncertainty relative to what the
estimated payments um are going to look
like for calendar year 25 but I don't I
don't think we're going to continue to
see a significant decline in revenues
the CCO cap is now fully in effect and
um businesses I I believe um have kind
of done that right sizing of their
estimated
payments okay moving on to page
three the meals and rentals tax just as
a reminder the majority of the tax about
80% is meals 18% is rooms and 2% are
motor vehicle rentals year-to date we
are uh 6.9 million or 3.3% ahead of plan
and 6.8 million or 3.3% ahead of Prior
year things to think about is how
inflation has impacted the cost of meals
um travel trends that we've seen you
know post pandemic as we've talked about
I think everybody realized how much they
like to eat out and how much they like
to travel and so we've kind of seen a
new Norm relative to um travel and the
benefits to M&R Revenue associated with
that and then two things that are unique
to the meals and rentals tax there is a
transfer as we talked about to the
municipal Revenue fund this goes to U
municipalities this is roughly 30% of
the tax it's a little bit more of a
convoluted calculation than that but
it's roughly
30% and then School building a Debt
Service which there is a schedule for
that um both of those Chris has a lovely
calculator for that and he will
calculate those for you so all you need
to worry about is um kind of the gross
revenue and then he'll do the
calculations to deduct the municipal
Revenue transfer and the school building
Aid so you don't need to worry about
that so for fiscal year 25 um we're
looking at a gross M&R amount of 475.894
million when you take out the transfers
to the municipal Revenue fund and the
school building Aid you get a net range
of
331.82
[Music]
335.25926 would assume that we um that
amount ahead of plan does
decline and then for the high this
assumes the actual revenue for the first
seven months and then assumes that we
continue at that 3.3% for the remainder
of the
Year looking at growth ranges for 26 and
27 you'll see 2 to 5% in each year that
low of 2% is less than what we're seeing
now so it assumes that there is some
slowing to the revenue whether that's
the result of um inflation increasing or
prices increasing and that getting to a
point where consumers decide to consume
fewer meals and room rentals and then
the 5% is just again very typical growth
year-over-year um to M&R that's kind of
our average growth rate um and so that's
what I would put at the high end
representative elmy thank you uh I think
it's uh too early to
be to be estimating this but
um there seems to be a lot of
distress among the um people in the
middle and the lower levels of our
income span
um because the cost of housing is grown
so high and a number of other things
like that cost of
eggs and
uh and I'm
wondering if there's any sign that fewer
people are are eating out at this point
or whether they're going down to Burger
King instead of to
to uh Three Tomatoes which is a the one
of the fanciest places in
Lebanon so we have seen when you compare
to Prior
year during fiscal year 25 we have seen
some fluctuation so if you're looking at
July for instance which would be based
on sales in June July was 6% ahead of
Prior year August was 2% below
um September was ahead by six October
was 3% below November and December were
both good months at 8 and 10% ahead of
Prior year and then January was 1% below
so to your point I think there might be
a little bit of an impact of
um folks kind of re-evaluating what sort
of disposable income they have or what
portion of their income they want to
spend on things that are taxable under
M&R um so if that were to be a
significant consideration then I think
going with the low end of the range you
know that that would move you towards
the lower end of the range and if I
could just follow follow up follow up
all of that gets distorted by was there
good weather or bad weather in X
month sure
um I think we had a pretty good foliage
season yeah um and that might be what
seeing reflected in the November and
December which would be October and
November
Revenue um I personally like the snow I
know that's not a universal feeling but
these bits of snow that we've been
getting I think there's more snow
forecasted for Thursday and maybe again
over the weekend that's great um traffic
on 93 going north has been quite busy um
and so that will be beneficial um to us
minus having to deal with the no yes
when you said January was down 1% is
that from the previous January that's
from the previous January okay
yep and that little of a change could
honestly just be due to the municipal
Revenue transfer because that's the net
amount um not the gross and the
municipal Revenue transfers based on the
prior year Revenue so we could have had
a higher transfer in that month which
would result in just that little
decrease okay thank you um did I see
someone else no okay thank
you tobacco
tax so fiscal year to date we are 18.1
million or 14% below
plan we are 5.6 million or 4.8% below
prior year stamp sales are declining
we've talked about that but other
tobacco products including ecigarettes
those sales have been
growing and other things to consider
again as we've discussed avail of
products in surrounding states and that
crossborder elasticity how much um
demand are we seeing from people coming
across the border to buy tobacco
products here in New
Hampshire so for fiscal year 25 again we
have a pretty tight range of 182.5
million to
185.30 14% that we are currently below
plan that that would stay for the
remainder of the prior um remainder of
this year for the last five months so
basically the trend against plan will
just
continue and then the high
assumes that the remainder of the year
will actually go back to being what it
was in the prior year so even though
we're 4.8% below prior year that maybe
we've kind of reached the bottom and
that we will be equal to Prior year for
the last five
months looking uh at fiscal year 26 the
range is- 5% to minus 3% and then for 27
we're at minus 3% to um just flat growth
those of you have been on the committee
for a while might know that minus 3% was
always kind of my go-to um
recommendation for tobacco tax revenue
prior to um the taxation of ecigarettes
it was just a pretty constant Trend
minus 3% year-over-year
we then had covid and the Banning of
products in other states which increased
our
Revenue but we have are seeing that kind
of Trail off and kind of go back to
normal Trends so that's where that kind
of minus 3% comes
from any questions on tobaccoes Aly look
like you have a question on I yes I
think I think we may have discussed this
before on we have an extremely low tax
on on cannab
products and
uh the qu and the we know that that is
growing that people are switching from
cigarettes that we tax at fairly High
rates but lower than everybody else
around us uh
and and there is a gulf between that and
what we're taxing cannabis products and
um is there any way do you think it
would make a significant difference to
segregate out out that product and
multiply it by two or something like
that um when you mean when you say canis
do you mean ecigarettes ecigarettes okay
um so and other vaping and other yes
other vaping products so um just as a
reminder ecigarettes are taxed as
representative Aly said at a different
rate than traditional cigarettes and add
a different rate than other other
tobacco products um and that rate
depends on whether they're a clothed
system or an open system um you know
where you're just buying um the liquid
as opposed to a clothed system where
everything's contained and when you're
done with it you throw it out
um we could look
at what the impact would be if just
ecigarettes continued to grow let me
just look at where we
are so fiscal year to date we're
basically flat to Prior year relative to
ecigarette
revenue um it fluctuates month to month
but basically at this time last year in
fiscal year 24 we had 5.5 million in
Revenue related to ecigarettes and in
fiscal year 25 through January we have
five .45 so we're about $500,000 off
so sure so fiscal year 24 through
January ecigarette revenue was 5.5
million and fiscal year 25 through
January ecigarette revenue was
5.45 where we are
seeing growth recently is relative to
other tobacco products that are not
ecigarettes so those are taxed at the
full OTP rate of 65.0 3% that has grown
20% year to date what are other tobacco
products so that would be your pipe
tobacco your loose tobacco your chewing
tobacco
[Music]
your single cigarettes GLS yep um any
sort of like like pouch or I am not well
versed in tobacco products but any sort
of um like pouch that you would put in
your mouth um those sorts of
noncombustible
yeah to call them
Bandits there's lots of
terms um um could you that was 45
million so that was last year fiscal
year to date through January for other
tobacco products that are not
ecigarettes was 14.4
million and this year fiscal year to
date through January were 17.3
million so combined ecigarettes and
other tobacco products year to date were
right around 20 million a little bit
higher than 20
million total toal tobacco tax revenue
year-to date is 111 million so still the
majority of our revenue is coming from
stamped
cigarettes could I just get a
clarification yes on the uh EIG include
uh the open system correct thank you
correct repres
y thank you in the past we've U
benefited substantially from Vermont
Maine in
Massachusetts um won't say anything
about New York people
bringing but anyway the uh question is
do you have a historical analysis of a
percentage of increase that takes place
when our biggest competitor
Massachusetts would
raise X number of cents New Hampshire
benefits y number of cents or maybe X
Plus
sense I don't have that offand it's
something that we could look into the
only thing that I have a caution based
on recent history is and the the best
example is when Massachusetts banned
flavored products right so you couldn't
buy menthol cigarettes in Massachusetts
anymore that resulted in a pretty
significant increase in demand for um
menthol cigarettes in New Hampshire we
heard that from the wholesalers we heard
that from the
retailers it's not a
forever bump it tends to bump at the
initial
change and
then either it has the intended effect
of the band and people of the ban and
people decide not to purchase that
product anymore or they find other ways
to purchase it other than coming across
the border so whether they purchase it
online or do something else
so sometimes those bumps result or
sometimes those changes result in an
initial bump but it's not a
sustained change or increase to the
revenue follow up um thank you Mr chair
both with meals and rooms and since
we're terate both with meals and rooms
and with
tobacco um it it seems to me that that
initial bump uh based
upon concurrent changes in tax law of
our neighbors plus the arc that follows
that might be beneficial for
prognostication if we know that for
example Massachusetts has already
indicated that they are raising their
taxes
by some stupid number um to raise less
money okay
um that would benefit
us in a certain category uh of
percentage
range um real dollars aren't important
because they've stop being
important um it's the percentage of
change so if we have some idea what the
bump is and then what the the following
Arc is yep whether it's up or down would
give us a an an idea on these two
tourist taxes right exactly where you
well this one in alcohol as well I mean
right where you would want to be within
the growth range right and I'm also
aware that uh liquor is spending uh uh
some strong energy on Border
Stores um to take advantage of that but
if if we had some real numbers I think
liquor and uh your tobacco retailers
could then rely on maybe I need to hire
a couple of more people maybe I don't
whatever it's that information would be
beneficial thank you let us well isn't
let me just um say isn't the information
you're asking for uh presupposes that
mass is increasing and are they in the
process of
increasing yes Mr chair mass is is in
the process they always are but is in
the process of
increasing uh from what I've heard um on
radio programs and you know the news and
stuff like that it's anecdotal at this
point till they actually do but when
they actually do we we
benefit and it would be interesting to
know what we benefit and whether the
follow on is what the what I'm looking
for rather than anecdotal we know we
know we benefit but what do we benefit
is the question sure let us go back and
see if we can
isolate see if we can find a time where
a rate change where we can really
isolate a rate change one concern so
when they banned the the the flavored
products in Massachusetts it was also at
a time that we were just seeing
increased consumption overall due to
covid so I wouldn't want I don't think I
have a way to isolate that and I
wouldn't want to conflate the two but
let us look back at when they've done
just strict rate changes and see if we
can see what might happen see if we have
any data that would show yeah I I would
suggest going back to when uh
representative Aly was a chair and
representing um major were chair we had
a similar discussion
uh what five seven years
ago yeah but the see we can isolate it
sure thank you representative om yeah I
just had kind of a high level question
here we're talking about numbers around
$29 million but looking at the chart
that says tobacco tax 182 million so can
you is that the national settlement that
makes up that big oh no so when I was
saying the um the number that I was
quoting was fiscal year to date so we we
have
111 million in tax fiscal year to date
and roughly 20 million of that Revenue
fiscal year to date is from OTP and
ecigarettes
so you don't have the full so the 185 is
the five more months of Revenue you
don't have the full year in
that the tobacco settlement I believe is
going to be estimated separately um with
numbers provided by the Department of
Justice if I'm understanding his concern
when you look at low of
29.7 if that's 7 months you're never
going to get to sorry that it's it's
written a little awkwardly that's 29.7
million or 14% below plan so in those
first seven months or or is that at the
end of the year the low estimate assumes
that we would end the year 29.7 million
or 14 it's just a coincidence that it's
very close to the other numbers that we
were talking about representative
elmy thank you um another thing that
worked back in the day when I was first
chair uh Brian gotl came in he's he's
the gentleman the the conservative
Economist who used to be a consultant uh
that that is producing all of our labor
work estimates at this point on he did a
um analysis of the what was affecting
the tobacco tax um revenues
and the thing that came out strongest
was the difference between the price of
gas in New Hampshire and Massachusetts
Connecticut uh on down
through through even New York uh that
people would come up uh knowing the they
could get get a lot cheaper gas at the
same time that they were getting cheaper
cigarettes and um and maybe go skiing or
something and
um it was an interesting analysis and we
we aren't haven't been looking at that
lately and I don't know whether it would
be worth looking at it again I think
part of that I I remember that analysis
I think think part of that
um assumes that the the main way that
people purchase cigarettes is in person
yeah which I believe is true but I think
there's probably more of an
online availability of pro of certain
products at this point more so than 5 10
years ago um but yes there there was a
the price of gas was definitely um a
factor in the number of of stamps that
we were selling packs of cigarettes that
we were
selling thank you thank you oh followup
yeah um well just for information
purposes um the tobacco settlement
requires and I think does some of the
work themselves uh that that we go after
any uh
untaxed
uh uh New Hampshire consumers of tobacco
online yes there's diligent enforcement
Provisions within the tobacco settlement
in order to ensure that um we we lose a
lot of money if we don't do it
correct I've got a whole group at Dr
that that's their job is to audit
tobacco so for diligent enforcement
purposes okay on to page
five interest and dividends dense
tax I'm just going to cut to the chase
on this cuz there's a lot going on here
and I think really what you need to know
is that the tax was repealed as of
January 1st
2025 we will receive Revenue in 2025 for
tax year
2024 but we're not going to receive
April and June estimated payments in 25
and we're not going to really receive
any money in 26 or
um I
would if you assume
that our the revenue that we
receive um without the tax being
repealed was going to be equal in 25 to
24 so no change and then you apply the
repeal based on the timing of
historically how revenues have been
received
revenue for fiscal year 25 would be
134.5
million you would have 8.7 million of
Revenue in 26 and then you would have no
Revenue in
27 so you can I'm sorry what was 26
again 26 was 8.7 million so that can
essentially be your be your Revenue
estimates 8.7 in 26 and none in 27 that
8.7 residual in 26 is um we still have
audit and enforcement and collection
Authority um not everyone is able to
file their returns and pay on time um so
there is a little bit of residual in any
year that we're collecting from prior
years so that 8.7 is just kind of
showing a little bit of residual that
will will come in in fiscal 26 and then
I wouldn't count on any Revenue in
27 represent elme
thank you uh your um blue
section says that you don't believe
there's going to be any
significant Revenue coming out uh in 26
or 27 correct 8.7 so just under 10
million is essentially the result in 8.7
and then in 26 and then nothing in 27
that's correct
okay thank you page six is the
communication Services
tax this is one of the smaller tax types
roughly $30
million so fiscal year to date we're
400,000 or 2.3 million below
plan and 900,000 or 4.9% below prior
year
um again we've talked about this in the
in the prior
sessions this is just a shift in how
people are using two-way Communications
the move away from having a cell phone
and a landline and then also kind of the
shift in your billing on your cell phone
plan and dedicating more of your bill
towards your data as opposed to your
voice or two-way
communication so the range for fiscal
year 25 again is quite small 29 .1
million to 30 million the low assumes
the first s months of 25 plus
the
4.9% that we've been below plan for the
last five and then the high assumes that
we meet plan in terms of growth rates
for 26 to 27 minus 3% to zero so again
as as we've talked about we've seen a
bit of a decline in the tax but it seems
to have kind of evened out um so I would
anticip I wouldn't expect it to grow but
I wouldn't expect it to significantly
Decline and is that decline primarily
the 3% decline primarily landlines going
away I would say at this point it's
probably the shift in your billing on
your cell phone dedicating more of your
cell phone bill to data which is not
taxable and less to texting in voice um
which is taxable I
see
okay um I just for reference um CST fell
about just about 3% from 22 to 23 grew
slightly from 23 to 24
um but it's been fairly consistent at
that 30 million over the past few
years is any do we have any idea why it
grew from 23 to
24 it honestly could just be the timing
of payments and when you know when we
say grew it grew from 30.1 million to
30.6 million okay so yeah it that could
just be a timing difference in terms of
potentially a late payment or an early
payment um I guess I'm just looking at
these numbers again 22 to 23 went down
3% 23 to 24 grew slightly so um
it's not like so I understand even
though it's potentially a timing issue a
decrease of 3% for the next over the
next two years um each year might
actually be too much well looking
further back from that there was a
decrease um from 20 to 21 of a half a
percent from 19 to 20 a 3.6% decrease so
I'm not seeing any like looking
backwards I'm not really seeing any
growth that's why I think that 1.7% 1%
growth is probably just an anomalous mhm
I wouldn't forecast any growth related
to this tax
okay but it's possible that the 3%
decline in in both those years could be
well that's why you have it on the low
range yeah okay right I think that's the
worst case
scenario all right thank you
page seven real estate transfer
tax so fiscal year to date we are 8.9
million or 6.5% below
plan and we are 8.6 million or
7.2% ahead of Prior Year we're seeing as
we've talked about a little bit of a
recovery relative to the real estate
transfer
tax you will need to um estimate the
gross and then there is a $5 million
transfer to the affordable housing fund
that happens every year so that will
come out after you've applied your
growth and Chris will handle that for
you things to consider Mortgage in
interest rates at their current rates
they seem to be
steady um I think that has likely pushed
people out of the market um but at some
point if they remain where they are
people are going to get tired of waiting
if they don't think that mortgage rates
are going to come down I think you will
see people enter the
market median sale prices as we talked
about have remained High um and then the
lack of of inventory um continues to to
be a
problem so for fiscal year
25 the low after transfers of
197.4 and a high of
2011.1 the low assumes that the
remaining 5 months of the year will be
at that um
7.2% ahead of Prior
year and the high assumes that we will
uh reach plan in each of the months
remaining I will say that
7% ahead of Prior year that has
been effectively growing each month
we've been performing quite well
ahead uh quite well compared to Prior
year so I there is a bright light we
started the year in July at um 3% below
August was 6% below that same month in a
prior year but then we've grown 14 16 12
10 and 15% for each month respectively
so so Rett is showing some signs of life
after a couple years
of decline
repres El me I think that this would be
a question for the
Realtors but how much of this may be the
growth in um
corporations investment companies
investing in New Hampshire Housing and
then raising the rent on rentals
we've had some of that effect I think in
Lebanon um if you bear with me for one
second
so if it is a real estate holding
company that's
transferring ownership in holding
companies those are reported to us
separately um and they don't come
through the
counties um I can say though that the
county transaction
totals fiscal year to date are 3% ahead
of the prior year so we we are I think
just seeing being not to say that what
you're um discussing representative Aly
isn't happening but I will say that that
is not the sole reason why we're seeing
an increase in R we're seeing underlying
increase in transactions at the county
level so potentially multiple things
going on
there representative Spar wouldn't the
increase also be the fact that we've
seen substantial appreciation of
property and and you've got a transfer
tax that's based on the value of the
property correct so whenever we talk
about the real estate transfer tax we
have to talk about both sides which is
you can have the higher
transaction um amounts and decreased
transaction numbers you can have higher
transaction numbers at lower costs but
at some point that breaks I think what
we're seeing right now is both we're
seeing the transaction volume increase
and we are at historic highs for the
median prices so I think both of those
things are driving um
the real estate transfer tax revenue at
this
point represent
opal thank you Mr chairman um
commissioner could you just you you
indicated you were just saying month by
month the comparison of 25 to 24 yeah
and and if I'm remembering or if I heard
it correctly it sounded like we were
doing better in months that would not
typically be favorable to real estate
sales but the winter months
correct or late fall winter am I
remember am I getting that right you're
right and so those numbers that were I
was reading off were comparison to the
same month in the prior year um and to
that same point we are seeing increases
in the transaction volumes again same
months to the prior year so these are
months that if we were seeing decreases
I would just say yep that's what happens
this is just a tough time a year to sell
a house nobody likes to take pictures of
a house with snow in the front yard you
know it always looks better with
flowers um but it seems like there is
increased activity that's enough to kind
of overcome those those lower
months follow up Mr chair follow up so
did I just hear you correctly so at
least the compared to Prior year it's
not just an increase in amount it's also
it's not just an increase in the value
of the property it's also an increase in
the number of transactions
correct um
correct which which may be indicative of
people getting tired of waiting perhaps
right getting tired of waiting
acknowledging that maybe the interest
rates are not going to come down as fast
as they went up and needing to kind of
jump into the
pool thank you RS and vs thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so approximately if you have an idea how
far would the rates have to come down in
order to stimulate buying just the rates
themselves the other half of that
equation is you need the
inventory so they've got to come down
enough to put people into the market but
then they there need to be enough houses
for those people to buy MH and that's
outside of my
expertise okay followup follow up so if
you would pass on to the realer
Association that you know it's not a
problem here in New Hampshire with snow
right I mean we have no bad weather
right what they need are pictures with
kids and smiles holding skis
right you can't see how dead the grass
is on my lawn when it's covered in
[Laughter]
snow any the Maple
Leaves right all right no more questions
on that no okay last tax utility
property
tax again relatively small
um somewhere around 45 million each year
but fiscal year to date we're 1.3
million or 5.8% ahead of plan and we are
6 million or 2.5% below prior year
as a refresher this is a tax where Dr
determines the value of the utility
property that property owner um pays
$6.60 per thousand of their uh
valuation um so as property values
fluctuate that will obviously impact the
tax any new property that's brought
online would increase the tax and then
um taxpayers do have the opportunity
even though we set the value they have
the opportunity to appeal it and so they
do appeal it and we reach an agreement
um that the value is less they have a
credit that's on file so the credit on
file can sometimes fluctuate the flow of
money um from month to
month so our low estimate for fiscal
year 25 of 44.3 million assumes that we
reach plan for the remainder of the year
and then the high assumes that we would
reach prior year revenue for the
remainder of the Year again very tight
44.3 million to 46.1 million and then a
pretty relatively low growth range of 0
to 3% in each of the next two years um
we I don't anticipate significant
fluctuations in the values of these
properties okay representative
elme
yeah
uh this um the utility property Tex uh
has been benefiting from increases in uh
in green energy to use a word that some
people don't like uh and Trump is trying
to close it all down is this going to
have some
effect so the amount of taxable property
so whether there's new property coming
online or property that goes offline
would impact the tax um
but these estimates don't assume
significant fluctuations to that
extent representative
YY there's proposed legislation I know
you don't deal with proposed
legislation so we're going to ask you
about proposed
legisl uh that will um regarding energy
generators the generators yep yeah they
will not be paying the up but they will
be paying an increase rate if it's
shifted over to uh Statewide education
property taxes and uh swept is that
correct correct so that proposed
legislation would take um generators
utility generators out of paying the
utility property tax so let me back up
for a second what happens today is that
those utilities that pay this utility
property tax this Revenue goes 100% to
the education trust fund so those
utilities do not pay the state wide
education property tax known as swept so
they don't contribute to the 363 million
that needs to be raised from swept
because they're paying into the
education trust fund as part of this
utility property tax the bill that
representative erer is ref referring to
would take electric generators or
utility generators out of the utility
property tax and
instead they would contribute to the
363.15 needs to be raised so that would
decrease the amount of the utility
property tax and that bill would be
reflected um on the Surplus statement so
you would still estimate it as if
they're paying it and then we work with
the LBA um with the fiscal note of the
impact to upt relative to removing the
generators and that would get included
on the Surplus
statement thank
you okay okay thank you and then very
simply on the last page this just
summarizes everything into one handy
dandy chart so you have our range for
25 and then the range of growth rates
for 26 and the range of growth rates for
27 so this just takes everything and
puts it in one nice easy to reference
Place nice
questions yes represent
shamberg thank you m Mr chairman and
thank you commissioner
I had this question at the very
beginning that I wanted to
ask your blue stripes through here your
estimated 25 to 27 estimated
ranges taking your analysis your
Department's analysis of everything
that's been going on this past
year do you have these estimated Revenue
ranges start starting in 2016
forward did your department make these
same analysis and the reason I'm asking
is I'd like to be able to look for what
you're doing now because it's
an turbulent time we're in all right in
in the economy I'd like to be able to
look back and see how close your
estimates were
to your crystal ball might be clearer
than our crystal ball okay uh I I I
don't know if you can do that or not I
know that representative opal asked
about
the what was
your uh liability and estimated payment
thing I know he asked about that and
then on your Revenue at the very end
your
chart would you be able to put that kind
of chart together for that same request
for 16 forward for those B those bium
years 16 17 18 19 20
21 I I don't know if that's too much
work but it it's like a baseball player
you know after so many years they start
to maybe their average is not good
enough or they're not for the team and
you might want to look for I'm afraid no
no not you're going anywhere I'm just
trying to put this together so that we
might go oh that might be too high or
too low compared to what's happened in
the past sure yeah let me think about
the best I want to be able to present it
in a way that's easy to understand so
we'll we'll look at that and see what we
can do and then you'll
know how accurate our estimates
are R elme thank you I think that the D
that the
uh
uh uh
l l lb AO sorry I'm I didn't get much
sleep last night um is um capable of
pulling that
together um every you've got this
information every single year going back
in your
records and it might make it
easier for us
anyway I'm happy I'm happy to do it I'm
only GNA do the years since I've been
commissioner though so I want you to
have a true reflection that's the
problem of Right For Better or
Worse oh but then we could see the worse
or the better right I don't want to
throw anybody else under the but Chris
did you have but but I just think to
represent am's Point yes we could help
with that we do have most of that
information I might need to get some of
the older years um that used to be paper
in our office and I'm not sure we have
it still
um but much of it's online as well on
our website and I think just one
clarification you're just looking for
the estimates that they provide when you
prepare the initial budget not any
revised estimates that come throughout
the
Bia that would make sense
yeah yeah could it could I bring up
something else oh yeah thank you on we
have the ability if we've got a computer
that will print it uh to print out
on these massive charts that we get
every uh every month at the end of the
month from
Dr about uh
the the
um
the the amount of money that came in the
the amount of money compared to the
prior year the amount of money that um
was refunded the amount of money and
estimates the uh all of the other things
um it might be interesting if um people
haven't been looking at that and I
haven't been able to print it out until
10 days ago are you talking about the
revenue Focus no not the revenue Focus
this this is a it comes to you every
month from the
Dr and it it um provides you every
single month of the
year
on past on and comparison to the prior
year okay and it it gives you all of
these different parts of of the picture
of where you end up right so it's it's
dr's month end reports we circulate
those very close to the last day of the
month it is the data essentially that
feeds into the revenue Focus much of
when I was quoting various comparisons
to Prior year in our conversation this
morning that's that's what I was looking
at is our month end report so I think um
it is a lot of data it's a lot there's a
lot going on there um I think you all
this morning hit on
the things that are probably most
important in those reports um those
reports are also summarized in some of
the other presentations I've given in
terms of business estimates extensions
returns um
so I think we've talked about a lot of
what's in those reports but certainly
anybody wants to to dive deep with us um
there's more information in there and
and the problem with those reports is
that there is no way to be able to read
them unless you uh have the ability to
do to either read them online or uh
print them on legal
paper
and that that does limit the use of them
by most people because they'll just look
at this and say this is too much we
can't get through it on
online we don't have a way to printed
out my printer I didn't have a printer
for a whole month and a half this winter
are they formatted in legal you could
they're formatted so that you can print
them in legal yep the font gets small
just as we try to get as much
information yeah as possible so it's a
constant battle if you print them the
other way it uh you will need a
magnifying glass
usually getting smaller all the time
yeah uh or or you scroll well it depends
the type of computer I I with my fingers
I can expand it on my computer so but if
you can't yeah that would be uh
representative Spar thank you Mr chair
uh the this is very helpful with the
revenue estimates uh we haven't touched
on I just wanted to ask are we going to
uh Lottery insurance premium I think
there were a couple liquor fortunately
those are not not my fortunately or
unfortunately Dr doesn't collect those
Revenue sources so thank right and we
had uh Lottery and and so forth present
to us um and cruset has put that into I
believe those things are probably in
this worksheet we have now on our
desk
okay representative opal thank you Mr
chairman um commissioner this may be
beyond the scope this may be
overwhelming but it occurs to me that
and this may even address potentially
representative ol's question um
you've done I I think a very nice job in
terms of sort of pointing out with each
tax things that we need to consider I'm
wondering as you're putting together the
scorecard
um you know to to stick with the
baseball analogy you know if a player is
injured one year his stats are going to
be down there are obviously factors that
may have
impacted positively or negatively
whether a an estimate in two years in
advance was you know for example covid
is obviously the big one I'm just
wondering if there is some ability in a
macro sense sure to put some context
behind the numbers sure I I was thinking
of that exactly um as I was worried how
my scorecard was going to stack up um
there are a few things I think over the
time period that we'll want to highlight
one is the tax cut and jobs act in
2017 um the
impact of covid um we very much revenue
estimates decreased um not just by Dr
but all the way through the legislature
significantly and then we outperformed
those because we didn't fortunately
didn't realize the impact that we
thought that we might see so we can
certainly footnote those sorts of things
for you um to increase my average
followup I mean just um you know as as
representative Erie said it might be an
opportunity to sort of take a look at
what our neighboring states were doing
with for example the tobacco tax sure
yep exactly thank you thank
you okay any other questions for the
commissioner one more yes I would love
to have those
footnotes we'll do we'll do our best um
forget the effective tax cuts and jobs
act and things like that we'll do our
best with those footnotes I don't you
know we could probably put half a dozen
in every year which I think would
diminish the effectiveness of the
footnote and so we'll certainly but try
to hit the high points and certainly in
years when we did not perform close to
what the estimates were if we performed
quite well well to the estimates I might
leave the footnote
out okay thank you very much thank you
welcome so just wanted to make sure the
members did see the worksheet I dropped
on your uh tables in front of you um I
also emailed that out to you last week
in PDF as as well as an Excel document
so that if you wanted to have it on your
computer and make adjustments to it as
you were thinking about your Revenue
estimates you could do that um what you
don't have in there right now is what
the commissioner just presented to you
today is the um basically the Dr related
revenues I didn't want to try to guess
that before I actually heard her speak
today
so but I will update that and if you
recall when I presented to you the first
day um when we talked about the
worksheet there'll be a page it will
take all those ranges and grow them and
show you you know what the high and the
low is in terms of the percentage so
you'll have numbers I'll take those
numbers and I'll plug them into the
worksheet so basically it just grows it
from year to year so if it's a the low
is at zero and the 26 and then zero and
27 it's going to stay the same you know
if there's a growth from 26 to 27
that'll be the growth in the low and
then I do the same for the High um so
that the the range becomes a little bit
larger when you have do it that way um
this is done this way because several
years ago um our office used to do an
average of those ranges um and the
committee decided that it didn't want
that anymore that it wanted the the
range to be able to work in between in
terms of the uh month-end reports I can
forward the email that you would have
all received from Dr when I get back to
the office so that you would get that
right now or essentially today so you
could see the reports that are being
talked about and as the commissioner at
um some of the responses to the
questions today she was using some of
those month-end reports which go back
several years and some instances and
it's on a month-to month comparison um
and in where it's appropriate I can try
to actually print some of those on the
legal page for you and bring it back at
lunch uh in the afternoon so that you
have
that um so if there's any other
questions or concerns or issues that you
guys might have let me know and and
we'll try try to address that so will
you have a um Consolidated uh you'll
have something to give us tomorrow
morning for Dr I will I will I'll update
I'll update this at the end of the day
um unless for some crazy reason I can
get it done at the lunch hour um but if
I can update it before I come back at
one I will if not I'll have it done by
the end of the day and I'll email it out
again for you to have tonight so when
you come back in the morning you'll have
the um the latest and greatest B Bas on
what you heard today um can we get a
print out as well yes for tomorrow yep
yep I always come with a print out but I
will always send it electronically
because there's a combination of what
people like to do with it yeah perfect
thank you Chris uh yes represent El me
thank you I don't remember ever having
the draft Capper come out this late is
do you have any idea of how much
variation there may be from so what that
says we don't expect a lot of variation
from what you see in this report I just
noted it in case there is any slight
adjustments before the final um the
extension was through the end of March
so the report should be almost
finalized um but the biggest reason for
giving you the information is the liquor
number from the cash at the end of the
year to what you see in the Acer and
what they presented to you was slightly
different it was about a uh 15 to2
million adjustment um and it had to do
with some of the
um shifting from their old computer
system to their new computer system and
reconciling some of the the numbers
related to that um so I didn't want you
to be using a higher number if you were
looking um at what 24 was estimated
at wow and it takes that long
to just fix that one section well
they're auditing The Liquor Commission
and and they need to reconciled and make
sure that the numbers that they're
looking at are truly the numbers that
should be reconciled so there's a a
growth or learning that's occurring with
the Auditors with the agency and
understanding that um the migration from
the old system to the new system and how
those two interacted and what they
should be seen as a result of that
migration so that's taken a little
longer than expected um some of the
reports that the Auditors typically get
earlier in the process didn't come until
much later um and and then they're
trying to understand what those reports
are and if they contain the accurate
information so that that's what some of
the delay has been related to that
portion
thanks anyone have any questions for
Chris okay seeing none thank you Chris
so I think we're coming back at 1:00 to
maybe do do some of the easier pieces of
uh Revenue estimating that would be the
plan uh we'll come back at 1:00 and
we'll do some of the easier ones uh
we'll we'll definitely have to spend
more time on business taxes and things
like
that okay all right so um that's that's
pretty much it for this morning um we'll
come back at one o'clock and start doing
a work session on this stuff thank you
for the Democrats present it's the
Webster room and I don't know whether we
should just go there now
or
yeah I was bullied into bringing my
lunch which makes it pretty difficult
could all the Republicans stay in this
room um for um short time
or not it's your
choice how many do we have one
two three four five why would you do
that six
seven nine yeah there's nine of us here
yes
well
e
e e
105 um
we will get started on our uh and now
that we've heard from all all the
agencies we've heard from Dr we've heard
from liquor
Lottery and so forth um and as Chris
mentioned this morning we have these
worksheets in front of us which uh deal
with all the other agencies we've heard
from except Dr which that'll be
integrated in for tomorrow's uh
tomorrow's
session um tomorrow's meeting I should
say so
um before we um before we get started
looking at some of these I just wanted
to go around a little bit and see if
people have just you know in general
thoughts on where they think uh the
economy uh is headed over the next uh
year or two uh because ultimately when
we look at all these
revenues um we have to decide on high
range low range or May maybe out of
range maybe something different um and
and as we do that we not only look at
you know what's happening uh for example
the um uh tobacco tax we know less
people are smoking that's not
necessarily an economic uh issue U but
so I just want to go around um not I
mean if you don't want to speak you
don't have to just kind of anyone who's
interested wants to just say what their
thoughts on on the economy next year or
two are U I'm going to start with that
so I'll start uh over here on sir's surl
do you want to say something uh sure so
I mean from what we're seeing already I
mean it's it's a different
Administration uh there's we're already
seeing uh things
stabilize uh businesses are reporting
where they couldn't decide what was
going to happen from quarter to quarter
I'm now I've read articles where
businesses have a an Outlook of
stability so I I think we're going to
see the uh nation's economy
[Music]
improve I think by uh the current
administration's push for energy we're
going to see Energy prices
decline and I believe once we see the
energy prices uh declining which I'm
already seeing that where I buy gas it's
come down about cents a
gallon I think we're going to see that
uh everything is driven by energy so
we're going to see our grocery prices
decline uh fuel for the heating of our
homes Decline and if we're drilling I
mean if we start exporting we're already
exporting energy but if we start
exporting a lot more energy as I would
guess it it will it's going to happen
happen just like it was four years ago
then uh I I really think uh the economy
is in for a real good shot in the arm I
think we're going to see great things I
think we're going to see the interest
rates come
down and uh I'm very optimistic about
the next couple years I think we're
going to see sometime by Midsummer we're
going to see uh fuel prices down
interest rates down that's why I was
asking Lindsay about what the uh impact
could be on the Housing Industry but I I
think we're going to see those rates
coming down very soon
okay representative Murphy did you want
to add anything um yes I think uh the
tax reform I think will end
up getting you know it's going to end up
passing at the federal level and that's
going to put more money back in the
hands of the small business owner and
also I think the average American so
that may help our tourism industry which
is what I'm hoping so hopefully those um
meals and and uh other taxes will
benefit from that okay thank you
representative
Spar uh I worry about the debt load of
this country I think it's stifling our
economy and uh will continue to be a
problem with GDP I I do read The Wall
Street Journal and uh I'm concerned with
uh you know a number of uh foreign
countries that are substantially uh uh
you know underwater and uh I guess the
last risk I feel is what's happening
down in Washington and and how that
interacts also internationally and does
that put a lot of risk into the equation
of what happens with our economy and I
think it does okay president
shamber Mr chairman my thoughts upon
this byian budget coming up and what are
we've heard so far is the reason I asked
I wanted to see I think we've had a lot
of Revenue come into the state that was
not
particularly driven by are economic
engines uh
and I think we're high in our approach
to this I think we should be a little
bit concerned about all the new things
representative spars talked
about Economic Policy coming out of
Washington
DC
and I think that we should look at a a
lower number on a lot of these
okay represent
opal uh it probably will come as no
surprise that I um respectfully disagree
with most of what representative or said
um I think in fact the threat of tariffs
will has and will continue to
destabilize uh business I think we heard
from um both commissioner Carswell and
others who said that tariff would have a
dramatic uh substantial impact on New
Hampshire's economy in particular Canada
is our largest trading partner um and it
and it could have I believe the word he
used was devastating impact um I think
that is that is at
best um an open question and I don't
know that we have uh any real answer on
that and so as far as that continues to
be a
sort of damle hanging over us I'm not
sure that we can do anything other than
um look at all of these
revenues um with the strictest possible
um approach thank you representative
Malloy thank
you uh I think what's been said and
probably what's going to be said is
going to
cover uh what you're overall question is
um but my
uh concern for New Hampshire is
housing and the ability to
uh keep and retain workers I think
that's the that's the drag
on if there is a drag on business right
now that's what's going to continue here
and that's what I focus on and I hear
that I live in
uh one of the most expensive housing
commun unities in the United States near
Portsmouth and Greenland and Rockingham
County and that's all I
hear cost of housing and I hear that
from uh people who
are have a generation coming up behind
them their children their kids their
grandkids uh and that just
puts a damper on a lot of things even
though a lot of other things are going
well but that's my uh that's my focus
thank you represent
elmy thank you I'm hoping that we can
discuss all of this through at least the
lenses of our own realism uh rather than
as a political
statement but I'm finding it extremely
difficult
to guess
how much longer the chaos in Washington
is going to be there and what is coming
out of it
uh and aside from the Tariff war wars
which we seem to be extremely close to
now from Trump's
statements um which would be disastrous
for everybody in the world including us
uh I'm I'm really worried about what
Elon Musk is doing to tear away the
confidentiality of the financial records
of a lot of the um
highest earning and uh on largest
corporations and as well as the smaller
businesses um he's going in there and
getting control of their financial data
he himself is a heavy Financial operator
and I think an awful lot of people must
be very nervous at this point about
competition and their ability to
survive thank you representative
y thank
you want to trying not to be political
so I won't say too much about Elon Musk
as doing his
uh limited legal
analysis of various agencies which is
something that hasn't taken place that
being said the Tariff issue I'm kind of
reminded of what happened when tariffs
were placed on uh European wines mostly
Italian and
French the American wine market took
off France I excuse me California New
York wines became very popular and we
even have wineries in New
Hampshire interesting how that
works I'm
also not very concerned about the Tariff
Wars
because nobody wants to have them so
people are willing to take a look at
their own
practices and work with their other
trading
partners I think that uh has already
been shown by various uh actions uh most
immediately by Mexico and by
uh um Canada and uh even some of the
South American countries regarding the
repatriation of immigrants but that's
into the political
realm within the United
States the
current uh situation
of too much money being on the mark the
M2 number is huge and being so large
makes it difficult
for there to be a real accounting as to
the cost of
eggs uh some of the uh fraud and
deception that has recently been
reported including the unwarranted
destruction of millions of uh chickens
laying chickens um
for no reason other than the director
ordered
him uh
destroyed uh you begin to wonder if
there's some mations taking place that
could cause
damage but within the first quarter I
think we're going to see a lowering of
returns but after the first quarter I
tend to agree with uh representative ORS
that when the uh spring Market comes in
and we get rid of this white stuff
that's complicating
travel we should probably see an
increase I'm I'm
optimistic cautiously
optimistic thank you Mr chair thank you
representative
om yeah thank you Mr chairman like
representative Spar I tend to look at
the financial press and think about some
of the macro issues that are affecting
the
economy and the ones I'm concerned about
are primarily the federal deficit we've
added $8 trillion do to the deficit that
affects us directly with interest rates
and interest rates directly affect our
housing situation with mortgage rates
around
7% uh people are not getting
the uh turnover and housing that we
would have expected which affects our
EST State transfer taxes the data I have
says that you need to get the rates down
to about 5 and a half% to uh get into a
normal supply and demand of the
marketplace that's when people will give
up a mortgage and look at moving into
another
place so I don't see the federal deficit
coming down much in the next couple of
years probably still in a trillion to
two trillion dollar range which I think
will keep interest rates high and keep
treasuries you know closer to 5% 10year
yields and until that drops about half a
point or more I don't think we're going
to see
much effect onto our housing prices in
the housing
revenue on oil prices uh the notes I
have here say it looks like 75 to $80 a
barrel for the next uh period despite
the fact that there's going to be more
drilling going on and more sources of
energy um so I hope that's going to
bring prices down a bit but the big un
known of course as the geopolitical
risks and that we thrown much control
over so I tend to be a little bit on the
cost side uh the forecast that Kiplinger
has for next year is is basically 2.5%
GDP growth up from which is down from
2.8% this year and I'm kind of inclined
to say the unless I could see other
Trends I'm looking at a flat growth for
the economy in in nashille thank you Mr
I'm sorry no Hampshire thank you Mr
chair thank you representative boltim
but tell us what about Nashville no um
so yeah it looks like uh we're probably
you know get maybe a 1.6 two point U
bump next year but also they're talking
about a contraction the year after so um
I don't think we're in for a great ride
um as far as n Hampshire I'll defer to
our ranking but with all the court cases
kicking around uh YDC education Men's
prison uh that's not a court case um
it's going to be kind of a rough ride to
try to you know backfill all that that
cost that's coming down the pike and
also housing is critical education is
still pretty much up in the air um as
far as like funding and um whether or
not vouchers rule um and I think the you
know the costs the interest rates are
such that it's going to be a rough ride
for many people people that are kind of
in limbo trying to look for a job in a
house for the next couple
years thank you thank you representative
sodi yeah um I'm uh optimistic uh New
Hampshire is a small state that's pretty
well-run and I think we're affected at
the federal level more than anything
else and I think it looks like um Trump
uh this time around might have taken
some inspiration from uh Javier Malay
with the aera and getting rid of the
waste and abuse and I think that's only
going to be good for our debt and only
going to be good for our country so let
the aaring
continue representative
Ford I'm um cautiously
optimistic um I am concerned about the
national debt it has has worried me for
years and it seems like it's only
increasing and that's why the reduction
of the federal Workforce is important to
me um um I I see the tariffs as a
negotiating tool at this point I don't
know how much will become a reality but
um I would I would like to think that
the first quarter because of the transs
uh because of the administration
administrative change it might be a
little rocky but I think it will
increase by quarters two three and four
thank
you representative
Brier I'm more pessimistic than all of
you I'm
sorry yes eventually like uh sirel said
the economy will be getting better I
don't apologize fast let me just
apologize representative tyy okay I I
don't think it's going to be anywhere as
near as fast um it may take place in uh
the first quarter of the next federal
fiscal year but I don't think it's
coming anywhere sooner than that uh the
debt is one thing that's holding it way
way back and the only way you're going
to get the debt under control is you
don't spend more than you take in and I
don't see that happening anytime soon
regardless of who's in
control thank you now representative
Brier
um I think that uh what I know is the
more fuel inventory you have if they're
going to do more actually produce more
crude more oil uh as your inventory gets
larger the prices will come down and the
oil price do tie tie into uh you know
because every every product you have has
to go to market so as the cost of
Transportation so I agree with that
comment uh as far as interest rates I
think there's going to be some play with
the interest rates but not enough
necessarily I think I think New
Hampshire is still going to have a
housing crisis for the next two years I
don't think that's going to get resolved
anytime soon um I'd be uh like it's
already been said I'd be very cautious
on uh what to expect cuz I I would I
don't think there's going to be a lot of
play in the revenue um and I I do know
that I used to be on the other side of
the table providing estimates and I know
that a lot of thought goes in by the
agencies when they're coming up with
their estimates and uh I will say that
they are the experts and I I think we
should trust them with the estimates and
that's just my two cents thank you it's
it's a that's a good perspective Ive
from from the other side of the table
um yeah I guess I um my thought is that
um I'm optimistic for the longer term I
think um as we look at the next year um
even even if we're you know in a more
positive uh thought process uh it's not
going to happen immediately I think the
probably for the next year it's uh we
may see a little bit of change but I
think it's going to be fairly flat uh
and and with some potential upside for
2027 but I agree with the statements
about the debt uh being awful large I
think it's the debt is close to one
trillion now per year which which report
I heard the other day is now larger than
the defense budget so that's that's just
really bad the debt needs to get under
control and that's going to stifle
economic growth for the country and thus
uh New Hampshire to some degree so
um yeah so I think we need to be uh
cautiously um
optimistic thank you okay now let's take
a look at uh what crochet has put
together for us um the first part of
this is the general and education trust
fund work sheets which includes as you
can see across the top business taxes
um so Chris when you when you have
business taxes you have you combined
um bet and B PT there yeah they are
reported as a single number to the
committee you make your estimate based
on that okay um as the committee may
have real uh seen in the revenue Focus
um for the last I think since August
time frame the business taxes have been
shown as a combined number because there
was so much interaction between the BET
and BPT so some of the numbers were in
the BET were looking way off and was
causing a lot of confusion but your
overall number was okay and there was a
couple of reasons for that um waiting to
see what what the governor does in terms
of um how she presents her her business
taxes if it'll be in a single line as
well okay so how have we done it in the
past have we reported we've split it
we've split it and that's that's what
caused some of the problems this last by
Anum is that we make the estimate we
used was too low on the BET or too high
on the BET side and so it looks like the
BET wasn't generating the revenue it
needed to but it had to do with um the
split between the BPT and the BET was
incorrect when we projected it okay
represent Aly yes uh we were going and
despite my protests uh with 60 40%
roughly uh splits for quite a long time
and as the economy has progressed so
that it is mostly profits that are
growing rather than imp uh cost of
employment um we down to um 20
27% bet is it well she she reported
78.3% BPT and 21.7 bet yeah and and it
fluctuates a little bit um in in that 70
to
73% uh BPT presumably that could
fluctuate again back do we have are you
expecting to have to to increase the
difference between the two or stabilize
or I I don't believe they think it's
going to be shifting back as much um
again you referenced the 6040 split that
has been traditionally been used um that
was a number that was kind of Applied
prior to the rim system being put into
place and some of the data that they can
now see so the Department of Revenue
Administration can um see when you pay
your the rate payer pays that the prior
year X percentage was BPT X percentage
was bet and they're applying it to those
buckets now whereas before if a rate
payer said oh it's 5050 they would apply
it 5050 or if they said it was 100% bet
and no BPT they would apply it that way
and so there was adjustments throughout
the year now that they see the real
number um they they know it's not 6040
um and it's it's
been uh since the end of last year
you've been seeing the 70 70 to 73% of
BPT and and the balance being the BET
and again why you saw a lot of
adjustments in those numbers and why the
the decision was made um with Dr and
administrative services to start
reporting it as just as a single
business tax number that's how you
estimate it in this room that's how they
provide the information when they come
in that's how they provide it when they
work with the governor um if you ever
needed to see the information behind
it's always there but in terms of
minimizing confusion going forward the
thought was just having a single
business tax estimate
asking what are the numbers that you
have in the
sheet
she
presented yeah right so if if you look
at the if you want to turn to page three
I'll just walk you through the
spreadsheet so everybody's on the same
page
yeah so that's your general education
trust fund um Revenue sources that that
you'll be looking at in the in the first
one under column as your business taxes
followed by meals and rooms Etc um Row 1
through four would be fiscal year
2024 row two is the official plan so I
think as we discussed at the beginning
that um at The Once A legislature passes
a budget and signed in law by the
governor Department of administrative
Services takes all the adjustments of
the estimates that were contained in
house bill one and anything that was
adjusted through House Bill 2 due to
legislation and they figure out what is
the the net number of reeven for the
revenue amount for each of the revenue
sources and then they come up with a
revenue monthly plan so what you're
seeing is the official plan for the year
so for on the business taxes it was 1.24
s um the draft ACA as was uh noted
earlier it's later than usual usually
it's due by 12:31 but due to some uh
unforeseen circumstances in terms of the
uh transition with Liquor's um computer
system it's taking a little bit longer
to get that ful F audited so they're
delayed but we were able to provide you
with a you know an as of 129 number for
revenues that you should see when the
ACT comes out at the end of the
month um so uh the annual comprehensive
financial report I'm
sorry so that's the annual audit that's
done on the state finances and and in
that um you get to see the for all the
different funds and and um activities
that occur you'll see the comments in
terms of their uh expenses and and where
they sit in terms of balances and and
surpluses or
deficits
um okay represent
Aly yeah
on it does say this on the first sheet
but uh people don't usually stay on this
first sheet very often this is millions
yes
yes so it's
1.24 s billion uh that was the official
plan yes y thank you but also the
um we do have to deal with somebody has
to figure out how to split where the
money goes between the general fund and
the education trust fund that somebody
might be
me yeah all by yourself yeah uh well no
I it we'll see it when the governor's
budget comes out we have an idea what
the splits are um in terms terms of you
know some of these taxes so for instance
like tobacco if you want to just to talk
about that we know that with the
cigarettes it's $1.78 a pack the first
dollar goes to the general fund anything
above a dollar goes to the education
trust fund we also know that all the
other other than um the OTP other
tobacco products and all the ecigarettes
all goes to the general fund so I need
to I know that based on today's
presentation it was at 17% is the OTP
amount so I would know that that that
would be going to the general fund and I
have a spreadsheet that I would use to
do that you would see all this your
final worksheet will have all the splits
so you'll see that and you'll know what
the education trust fund amount is
you'll know what the general fund amount
is I know that the business taxes will
be split 41% to the education trust fund
59% to the general fund I know that the
real estate TR uh transfer tax is split
um 2/3 to the general fund 1/3 to the AG
ation trust fund
um what other splits do I
have I think that's it so I think we
covered them um follow up could I uh
somebody asked me on is the governor
talking with the
LBA no about these things no so we don't
know until Thurs stay whether she's uh
using older data or so she works with
the agencies throughout the process okay
and so she's going to have um access to
the same types of information that
you've been hearing from the agencies
the last two weeks um but not the split
um oh she would have that as well the
Departments would help Lindsay's group
would do that yeah y thank you
yep yeah so so the first four lines on
that first page page three is just just
to give you what fiscal year 24 the
activity looked like um fiscal year 25s
gives you gives you the official plan on
row eight and then for rows nine and 10
we do the agency high
low most agencies it's just a single
number that they've provided you the
high low comes into play with the Dr
numbers where they give you their range
and that's what we plug in here so
tomorrow when you see this spreadsheet
for business taxes you'll see a low
number and a high number based on what
was presented today by the
commissioner um and then that's the same
we'll go we'll be done for 26 and
27 as this committee makes
recommendations or puts thoughts out
that you know we want to see the
business taxes and 25 at this number 26
at that number I'll start to populate
that as well so if today you decide on a
couple of Revenue sources you're like
okay swep we know it's
3631 based on law we don't need to
debate that tomorrow I'd come in with a
sheet sheet filled out with house Ways
and Means saying you agreed to
3631 um so that your general funds go
the first three
pages the last page on page five you'll
see is it totals everything at the end
um so it's looks low now until you get
all the Dr revenues in there and then
it'll um it'll pop up to be a couple
billion and then if you go to page seven
that would be the highway fund so as you
as you may call you have the highway
fund unrestricted Revenue as well as the
fishing game unrestricted Revenue to
estimate um so the highway
fund same process I give you the
official plan what the um annual
comprehensive financial report numbers
potentially are and then for 25 26 and
27 I give you agency high and low again
the agency only gave you one number so
it's the same in both places um you had
if you remember there was a single page
that safety provided that was a spread
sheet looking um document that had 20
had 10 years on it but had 25 26 and 27
what they thought and a lot of numbers
so the road toll was the first number
summed and then after that was all the
MV fees motor vehicle fees so I sum
those up and I add them here the 200,000
in the middle is what you heard do
present to you so it's just basically
the miscellaneous when they um um
dispose of surplus vehicles and property
um that would go into their Highway
fund and then the on page nine would
again be the fishing game again this
similar process um they presented to you
a sheet and you knew they licensing
fishing game licenses was the 9.8 and
the 10 million respectively and then I
summed up the rest of the um list that
they provided to give you the um
estimate for the other all their other
Revenue which is 4146 or four just over
4 Mill
ion typically when you make your
estimates you usually go to just the
first decimal the reason we go out three
places is because of what you see here
today like the act the annual
comprehensive financial report goes out
three places so we show that um and some
of the agency estimates will go out a
couple of
places um doesn't mean you can't go out
three places but it's just it becomes
more of a rounding era than
anything so that's that's the layout of
the document um I don't know if there's
any questions but like I said as you
make decisions or um agree to
potentially what your decisions might be
I'll populate it so that you have it in
front of you um everything is on our
website so any of the agency documents
that if you can't find it in paper you
can go out to our our website you can
pull up their documents see what they
had to say um you can pull up the
worksheets will be out there as well so
if you're at home because it's you know
and you left your stuff in your drawer
here um you can get access to that
information um and available you know if
you email me I can help you out with
whatever questions you might have as
well thank you representative El me
thank you two things one uh people
should remember that this is based on
current law now uh anybody brings in a
bill that adds or decreases Revenue that
is not considered it goes the them and
the the finance committee deals with
that and
um the other one was if we've got
questions when we consider
individual uh revenues that we should
have asked to the agency will you relay
them and bring them
back I will I will and depending on the
timing of what the committee has we'll
get them back as quickly as we can um Dr
will um have someone of available um in
the room as you guys are meeting um to
the best of their ability you
know they'll try to have someone here
tomorrow morning um they may not have
the answer right then but they'll know
what the question is and get it back as
quickly as they can um since they are
covering other bills and other
committees as well um so so they may
have some Manpower issues um but yes
absolutely and to your point reps andal
me um if you are looking at uh on page
three at the insurance tax
and you go back and look at the
insurance document you're going to
notice that what I have on um fiscal
year 26 and 27 on row 14 and 15 and 19
and uh 20 respectively are million
dollars higher each year than what the
insurance department presented to you if
you may recall they had a million dollar
um reduction related to a new program
that they wanted to implement that
program hasn't passed in law so that's
why I raised it back up and if you
recall I had said something to the
commissioner and he said oh that's right
yes um you that's correct put it back up
so specifically you're on page three yes
the insurance tax column so what are you
saying instead of so I'm saying if you
look at the sheet the department gave
you they're going to have an estimate of
158 and 162 okay that's because they
removed a million dollars each year for
a program that hasn't passed the
legislature yet so I've added it back in
if that does pass yeah um then we would
take care of that our office the LBA
would take care of that on the Surplus
statement so we would make a negative
adjustment on the Surplus statement okay
so you don't have to be thinking about
that the same with uh to what kind of
follow up with the Reps of me any bills
you have coming before you if you pass a
bill that um has a an impact on Revenue
either positively or negatively you
don't have to worry about what your
estimates were here today or in the next
few days that will be reflected if it
passes the Full House will reflect that
on the Surplus statement is the house
position
okay good thank you
um yes represent Brian thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question Chris um I don't know if you
have it handy but I was just looking
under the motor vehicle fees how much uh
how much revenue do inspections bring
in was it about 2.5 or was it a little
higher than that 2.5 million or
one moment sorry no no that's I can't
recall off the top of my head but I do
have it right
here they got it it just under 4 million
and 25 and then just over uh 4.9 and 26
and then 3.9 and 27
thank you that's registrations in one
year that's just just the a
motiv oh the inspections just inspection
stickers okay would be about five
million
okay well I think to I mean one of the
things we can do is we can we can work
on some of the obvious stuff first and
and knock that off um
I mean let's start at the end the end
here on page
nine and
um this looks like a real easy
one CH the total fishing
game
um oh the to yeah the total is wrong
there oh no it's not what do you mean
the total's wrong
no start at the last page which should
be the total sum total of everything
that is Happ oh oh okay so it's the fish
and game fund um and
uh we're just um Chris the thing that
goes into HB is it seven or whatever the
so there would be the unrestricted
Revenue in
hb1 is that the question well I I feel
like I looked at an older another year
and the when we submit our Revenue
estimates I feel like it was HB
something else so what the what we'll
end up doing is putting together a an
amendment or of a house resolution so
this committee will have a house
resolution in your name that will go to
the house floor house resolution 17 in
2023 resolution from that we will make
do an amendment to House Bill one the
unrestricted Revenue using those Revenue
estimates thank
you which all are developed based on
what you do with these worksheets and do
we need to do anything else with the
rest of FY 25 are we only looking at 26
and
27 so you you'll make adjustments the 25
is you feel that they need to be made so
and and when you do your house
resolution you'll see the there's two
columns for 25 so the one would be what
the a plan was and then any adjustments
that this committee made okay so you
could go up in some areas and you could
go down in other areas and you would
have a new Total that you're working
with for 25
so with this so on page nine you would
make estimates on row nine 14 and 19 and
that's what would be incorporated into
the house resolution yeah I see what
you're saying
okay yes represent
opal thank you Mr chairman um Chris just
so I understand if this committee makes
adjustments to
fy2 that budget's already been passed
asked so what is the effect or impact
does the house versus Finance then have
to vote to adjust the budget based on
that or how does that work so a couple
of things can happen one it um may be
the base that you're using to grow your
Revenue estimates in 26 and 27 but what
it does is it puts notice on that we
think the the revenues we projected in
23 are not doing as good or doing a lot
better than we anticipated and we think
that 25 will end potentially here what
will happen is that um if the governor
hasn't already started doing it in this
case um she's made started the effort by
freezing um uh hiring of positions um
there would be need to be some actions
taken to make sure at the end of 25 that
the budget balances so that you start 26
in a positive position and that will be
something that the um finance committee
would work
on and then presumably the Senate would
get its shot as well right same with
what and then presumably
finance and then the full house but then
correct the Senate would get it shot
right exactly yep yeah it go through the
whole process of um Ways and Means would
do its estimates go to those estimates
will drive what Finance is going to do
for an operating budget full body would
vote on that if it passes it would go to
the Senate the Senate would start that
process all over again um except for the
2023 budget usually there's a committee
a conference where you would come back
and and a subgroup of the finance
committee members with a cou usually a
couple members of ways and means would
meet and and um negotiate any
differences and then it would go back to
the governor if the legislature approves
it then go back to the governor to
either sign it veto it or let it pass La
into law without a signature and then if
it's vetoed we start a different
process thank you thank you Mr chair
representative
ORS thank you Mr chairman so Chris
thanks for taking my question do you
know if uh the p wish to sell a lot more
hiker safe cards are included in these
numbers I was talking to rep Spain and
no you don't know or no they're not hi
the hiker uh safety card is a dedicated
fund a restricted fund so any money that
goes into that goes into that fund
unless statutes change to direct any
increase to another place but this is
there this would be the fishing games
general fund they their money that
hasn't been allocated yet things like uh
the hike safe card or um you know the
non-game species accounts uh some of
these things that you may hear about if
you're in some of these other committees
are dedicated funds the the duck stamp
the Pheasant stamp you know those are
all dedicated monies for the Department
for those purposes representative Brier
thank you Mr chairman uh Chris uh
question are the unref unded road tolls
reflected in here at all they are yep
it's in the all the other all the other
okay
followup followup is that the most of
the other
or a big chunk of that's made up of the
UN it is a it's a um so in 25 it's
estimated it was uh 792 th000 of the um
ohrv unref unded road toll came in and
then just over a million in the Marine
unref unded road toll so going in 26 and
27 they they've projected um$ 850,000
and um a million dollars in each of
those two and it is their biggest other
okay that combined yes thank
you representative
jelery thank
you on the unrestricted
um rebates on the road
toll is that number going up or down and
why so the the number had gone up
um during covid the number went up so it
had been a fairly consistent number and
and I'll let repon Brier step in if I
speak out a turn here since he has maybe
more information than I um but it had
been a fairly uh consistent number and
then during covid um there was a lot
more um off tril activities and Marine
activity because people couldn't be near
one another so they were getting their
ohvs and their boats on the water so
there was a higher um licensing um you
know not license excuse me the higher
use of that so there was more claims
potential for unref unded road toll and
people didn't come forward and claim it
so it just goes into that that
pool they've come to a it's starting to
flatten out now at that numbers that I
mentioned when ripson Brier asked this
question therefore going forward we
should look around a million dollars
rebate yeah it's been that way for since
covid and they're not seeing it come
down significantly and the reason it
went up was because government
restrictions telling us not to get
together made people get together to go
out into the fresh air well I think that
people were going outside more often um
during covid and they saw that's where
you see an increase in the uh fish uh
the fishing licenses as well and the Hun
licenses
so sorry
I okay as I look at the um fishing game
fund here I see numbers that are very
very static and I'm wondering if
somebody um this probably could be
something we could finalize and vote on
um would would somebody like to make a
motion to I'll I'll make a motion okay
that
uh I'll make a motion that we accept the
recom recommended numbers from uh
fishing game for Revenue estimates so
that would mean the uh the estimate for
2025 would just be
13.9 uh so Chris you're recommending
that we for example 2025 we would just
say 13.9 there yes okay and what I would
do is I would adjust the um other column
to be 14 uh
4.1 so I would drop the uh 46 that's
there okay so you'll you can make those
adjustments based on what we decided
today okay thank you and when you see
this tomorrow you'll see that those
adjustments are there so if I don't do
something that the committee thought I
should have done you can correct me do I
have a second on representative R's
motion second by representative
Aly um Clark did you get
that probably should make a motion let's
see
Bri Mr chairman I have a question for
Chris while you're discussing what can I
ask Chris a question sure Chris looking
at the uh
let see what I'm fishing game fund and
looking at their
numbers there
was a a decrease in Marine unfunded road
toll an increase in un oh HRV unfunded
road
toll uh and then the interest savings
was an
increase do you see these numbers
changing
my question I guess my question is are
these numbers so close and static to
each other that that you feel that the
numbers that are on here
are are what we should be
addressing I do I I mean I would um
trust in what the department has
provided and I think the um schedule
shows that those numbers are fairly
static I mean they do fluctuate a little
bit but I think that they're projecting
um better than they may have in in um
prior to 19 so the numbers were a couple
hundred, less prior to 19 each
year um this the interest number goes to
what was talked about with the treasurer
the when she came in and having the pool
of cash that she's able to invest once
she invests that and she gets the
interest return she then parses it out
to those funds that are allowed to have
it allocated to it fishing game fund is
one of them that in statute it says
interest goes to that fund
representative opal thank you Mr
chairman and I'm I'm going to ask the
committee's Indulgence as a a first
termer um I'm not sure whether this is
the appropriate forum for this question
but relative to the fishing game fund I
have a constituent who asked me she uh
has a store in one of my towns and sells
the the permits for off-road um and I
guess the issue for for her is the
amount of time that fishing game is
giving her to remit the fees from the
sale and it's apparently it's a fairly
short period of time maybe a matter of
um two weeks at the most and she was
asking me about exploring the
possibility of extending that to perhaps
the end of the
month I'm not sure whether that has it
might have an impact on this I'm me
actually not even sure where to start in
terms of pursuing that but um I I
thought since we're discussing fishing
game I'd bring it up and if it's
completely inappropriate the chairman
would tell me to hush well I think what
I would suggest is that probably would
need to be in touch with fishing game
department and their Administrative
Office to find out why they're providing
the time frames that they are it may be
statutorily required which then would
require the legislature to do something
it may be internally they require
something to get the money so they can
account for it but I can't speak to that
in terms of impacting this it wouldn't
impact what you're doing today because
you're basing it on what's current
practice
today thank you thank you Mr
chair okay uh discussion on this uh we
have a motion to accept this as
presented by fishing game uh
representative um
Aly I realized I have another question
how much
interest is in these
numbers so the uh
the estimate for 26 and 27 was
250,000 the amount that um was was shown
for fiscal year 24 was just over
400,000 the budgeted amount was 100,000
for
25 so the department um again interest
isn't something that um has been
collected by agencies for quite a long
time until all the arpa and car's money
came into hand as well as the
um the fund having a balance to it the
efficient game fund has a a a bounce in
it so when the treasurer was um putting
things into interest bearing
um acts the fishing game fund has
benefited from that significantly prior
to um that you would see that the number
for uh 19,000 back in 22 back in 21 it
was
2500 um 20 it was
86,000 so it they never had a big number
there they have and they've been
watching it the last few years the the
legislature um leaned on the department
in 2023 because their estimate was
25,000 and they said you you seem to be
doing a little bit better than that can
we increase it for 24 and
25 um the administrator carried that
forward into 26 and
27 it's a long-winded response hopefully
I am answered your
question thank you CHR it appears that
we're not going to have as much in the
treasury right over the next few years
so the interest should be going
down it's it's anticipated that um
you're going to see 26 similar to 25 27
should come down a little bit overall
but um in 28 and 29 you probably won't
have the same balances because all of
arpa should be gone
um and then with fishing game when they
present it to you they they express the
idea that their fund is um uh
insufficient to support their operating
activities so they they don't think
they're going to have much of a balance
at the end of this by anym that's still
to being determined um but
she so yeah they it basically will start
to go away and they won't have as much
revenue I have a comment if I may sure
uh fish and gains Revenue has been
insufficient for its
activities for as long as I can
remember and it goes back almost 30
years so the fact that the interest uh
will be
less is that going to affect it doesn't
look like they're taking that into
account for
2027 um maybe it's because they expect
increased license
uh Revenue so I I can't speak to why the
department felt that was they were
comfortable at the 250 amount but I do
know that they were talking with the
treasur and others when they were
putting this together so um I'm not in a
place to say that's not a good number
um fair enough all right any other
discussion on this uh fishing game the
numbers okay then let's uh let's take a
vote on
this well if you look at page
nine then you will see what we're doing
is we are rounding so for the um
estimate on line nine it'll be
13.9
uh oh wait a minute I'm sorry uh well y
we do we fill in each of these items so
the licenses licenses and all other or
do we just do a total so I I believe
that what you want wanted to do was to
have um on row 9 column A be $9.8
million yeah row 9 column B to be $4.1
million row 9 column C to Total of$ 13.9
million 1.9 right and okay if I could be
as bold to just move you down to rows 14
and 19 which are the same I think the
committee was going to go with 10
million under row column a 4 million
under column B for a total of 4 million
under column C for both of 26 and 27
yeah but if I'm jumping ahead I
apologize no that's that's uh where I
was going so we filled that in
um does that answer your question
representative shamberg
okay any other concerns questions
comments before we vote on accepting
these
numbers okay sing yes repres B or is uh
really in all the numbers or
you um motion second well this so what's
going to happen correct me if I'm wrong
we're gonna we're going to vote on each
of the items and uh eventually it'll
Chris will take all this and put it into
a house resolution and then we'll vote
on the house resolution in here right
and then it'll go to the Full House
I'm sorry what was what was the
motion would you speak louder micone use
your
microphone if the initial motion was to
modify 9C and now we're going to be
modifying you know a b and c for nine no
we're not we're not modifying no we're
just uh placing it there to vote
on correct yeah so we're want amend
okay never mind no we haven't we haven't
amended anything so what
were're you were suggesting an amendment
we had a motion in a second yeah or not
the expanded I mean it's kind of
ludicrous but um you know we're
basically oh I'm s well maybe I
misstated it the motion uh who made the
motion the motion is to the whole thing
I was my motion was to uh take the
Department's recommendations and approve
it
right so it was for the whole for the
whole thing okay yeah all right okay and
and representative Al Mayu seconded a
motion for the whole table
okay very good so by a show of hands all
in favor of adopting this uh
table any
opposed okay seeing none it's uh I don't
know if we have to record the actual
just the only thing that counts is the
final resolution there the final
resolution rest just but just for notes
I'll two 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 Mr chairman did yes I know it's an
informal vote and it doesn't really
count till the resolution but how many
did you count 14 I think you missed
yourself did I miss one two three four
five six iount 10 11 12
13 14 is it 14
okay okay so we can check off fishing
game Mr chairman that was a good
accomplishment fishing game that's
checked off is it checked off
permanently well no not not permanently
no uh so we're we're going to go through
um we're not going through everything
today because as we talked about the the
Dr information that just came in of
course will present in a worksheet
tomorrow and we will go through each of
those items um and and eventually vote
on each one then when everything is all
done we've gone through everything he'll
put together a house resolution and
we'll that'll contain all the estimates
we've come up with and we'll vote on
that and then it'll go to the house
floor did that answer okay
represent opal you have a
question when Chris was mentioned
numbers and you were mentioning numbers
you said we'll have a 98 a 41 A
139 yeah we're basically there we're
basically rounding up to the nearest
10th nearest 10 okay yeah so 13
13.94% n
okay okay so that's fishing game let's
see what other straightforward Revenue
estimates can we take care of
P
okay the
highway the highway
fund I think the highway fund looks
pretty solid page seven the the only
concern I have which is uh well it's not
a concern yet but if if a proposed bill
passes we'll lose some revenue on the uh
about 4 .9 and 3.9 in inspection fee
Revenue but that's based on the current
statutes uh that looks very reasonable
okay and so if we fill in this table it
be a similar thing looking looking at
each uh if you look at column n um row
nine column A that would become 12
127.71 motor vehicle fees is
133.5 Highway
Revenue well no the total so the total
is
uh
261.5 and then obviously would line 14
and line 19 we would round each of those
to the appropriate
127.71
14.2
1317 and
[Music]
two did that add up right 14
260 oh I'm sorry 2596 yeah
lead on uh fiscal year 26 under road
toll uh was at
127.71 is at
127.0 correct
okay and then uh the final total on line
19 is 262.50
26288 oh yeah it's that's correct
2628 thank you represent
Aly I wish that we had asked more
questions at the
time I'm not really remembering but um
26 looks like it is
the the Lost year from having changed
from a four to a
fiveyear um registration
plan
um
but it doesn't look like a lot of people
are going to be buy buying new cars for
quite a
while at this point
and and but but the the the St State's
fee as versus the town fees are
dependent only on there is a car there
which is right a big car or a small car
and a luxury car
or it's registration plus the weight
what it's registration and then the
registration are based on weight yeah
right so think a navigator is going to
pay more than your W for just
I been followed by follow they've been
following me sometimes would someone
like to make a motion on this
one represent
ORS represent Aly do you second it
um I don't I don't think I'll second it
I'll vote for it okay uh representa tney
it's not be
yeah okay all uh any discussion any
further discussion on these
numbers okay all in favor show by
raising your
hand okay anyone
opposed NOP
okay now let's see if we go to page
five so the commissioner did not talk
about about uh Medicaid recoveries
correct that was the Department of
Health and Human Services okay that's
Health and Human
Services deps finding people sorry it
depends on finding the people who have
been on Medicaid and die leaving a car
or a house or something like that which
can be uh from which the cost of
Medicaid can be
sequestered and if you're part of a
couple and only one of you dies then the
other one gets to keep it for a
while
yeah so it tends to wander up and down
out of that small
amount
okay all right so in this case we are
just looking at uh column
Q um row 11 would be 2.2 column Q row 16
would be
31 and column Q row 21 would be
3.1 and these were the agency
numbers that is correct
okay someone like to make a
motion on me sure the general
population that is involved in
this um is declining so why are the
numbers going
up so as they presented um audits take a
little bit of time so they they will
continue to drop down going forward but
they suggested that there's some audits
in play that they may see that collected
in the next couple of years but you're
not going to see the
numbers um probably six years ago eight
years ago you used to see numbers in the
15 to $2 million range
um we refer to that as probably your low
hanging fruit they they've taken care of
that they've reconciled that now we're
getting to a point where um it's it's
going to be very small numbers and as
more and more of the
um individuals covered by Medicaid go on
the Managed Care contracts the managed
care companies are um um responsible for
doing this work and then it offsets any
future negotiations of what the state
cost
is so but they felt comfortable and
that's why they had suggested um the
number drop in uh fiscal year 25 you can
see the estimate was 3 million uh they
came in with 2.2 million because what
they see right now they're not going to
get there that they're not going to
um resolve any of their audits at by the
end of that uh the end of this FIS
year
um but rep M's Point earlier it's it's
been around the three two and a half to
three and a half million in the last few
years representa Aly I'm questioning
lines nine and 10 total they don't add
up to what
the official plan for the utility
property tax and Statewide retain
Property Tax Plus this is and they don't
add up to certainly don't add up to are
you looking at column R which line are
you looking at at the Total Line r that
would be all your general funds and
education trust funds so it's the three
pages in total so Pages three through
five
oh we're going backwards on the
worksheet so yeah yeah that's
confusing try so that seems pretty low
but you haven't put in other numbers
correct so once the Dr numbers are in
there it'll be um closer to what you're
seeing on the first row yeah it'll be
two billion and and some
change would someone like to make a
motion to accept
uh column Medicaid recoveries okay
represent Aly a
second
okay any discussion more discussion on
Medicaid
recoveries seeing
none the numbers are column Q so this is
all in column Q row 11
2.2 row 16
3.1 row 21
3.1 all in favor raise your
hand any opposed
no okay
wouldn't it be nice if the rest of the
columns were this
easy
that's I think colum ke could
be now is that all let's see if there's
anything else I think everything
else Dr brought today right um no
Lottery Revenue tobacco settlement okay
Other M M Mr chair before you leave page
five um the committee could look at the
swept since that's statutorily assigned
okay at
3631 for each year now we don't have low
and high estimates there I didn't put
anything in there CU I was waiting to
see if the Dr would just include it on
their stuff they but we all know what it
is it it doesn't change 63.1 yeah yeah
it the amount collected can sometimes be
a little bit higher but it has to just
do with how they set the rate and
getting it as close to 363.15
all right so um continuing our um
process of working
backwards um now we'll go to column p on
page
five so as Chris was just pointing out
the so now row so again just I'm just
talking about column P row 11
363.15 point1
and Road 21 363.15
okay um any further discussion on that
number
3631 seeing none all in favor of
accepting 363.15
okay
understand um represent El me yes I'd
just like to point out that this has
been constant without regard to
inflation since
2011 okay
okay
um so utility property TX that we did
discuss today so we
won't do anything with that
yet uh going to page
four
um well I guess we can yeah continue to
work backwards on page 4 so the the last
column column
n
um I don't think for our purposes we
heard testimony as to why they thought
these were the numbers I'm not sure we
have any additional knowledge that would
change these but would anyone like to
make a comment or do we agree that as
presented
we okay
represent okay um represent ative um you
making a motion to accept as
representative tyy is making a motion to
accept column
in Y
correct second on
that second
uh any
discussion all in favor raise your
hand anyone
opposed represent Murphy I assume you
uh you did okay all right
good okay
continuing to work backwards Lottery
Revenue
um I don't know is there any any reason
to expect anyone feel that that should
be different than as presented by
Lottery yes representative Murphy um did
we not discuss there's a bill to
increase the hours for Kino would that
make a difference doesn't matter okay
okay then no anything we do is based on
current law
even if you know it's coming up for a
vote in two weeks it's not if we're
still if we're working on this we just
based on what current LA is
representative
erery yeah and and to that topic uh you
know would be a small section but gaming
overall depends on what what laws passed
this year there may be a reduction uh in
gaming there may be an increase uh the
overall economy apply because when the
economy goes bad there's an increase in
gaming for some reason which
makes
umate yeah well that's true too but
so okay so um so the numbers if we
assume that we don't have any judgment
beyond what uh has been presented to us
by Lottery then column M Lottery Revenue
row 11
180.0 row 16
172.5 row 21
172.5 any further
discussion seeing none all in favor of
going with those
numbers okay anyone
opposed you're opposed and you're for
it I Less on game
okay all right continuing to work back
towards other what is what was other
Chris so other is the uh mainly the
interest on the money in the treasury
it's abandoned property and then about
200 other um accounts that agencies
deposit revenue from a lot of
Agriculture um some uh courts some um
safety
uh Corrections you know anybody that
collects money that's not dedicated to a
restricted fund it would go to treasury
in one of those accounts and be counted
as other secretary state has a number of
that of
those
okay it looks like that's uh pretty
static as well does anyone have any
thoughts on that represent El me we
usually got a long list of all of them
along with with um the amounts more or
less that they were providing but but I
don't think any of us ever got anything
out of that
list so so the department when they came
in Department of administrative services
along with the treasury Department
provided you a document where they
showed you uh about 10 to 12 of what
they would call their Heavy Hitters
which included abandoned property and
other and a couple of others and then
they provided a
list um in the back of the report of
like the 200 other fund that they
collect not the amounts that they get
because some of them are a couple
hundred dollars if that some could be a
few thousand so they tried to show you
the the the ones that were a million or
so plus and then all the other types of
revenues they collect so they did
provide that to the
committee when you when you bring the
updated spreadsheet
tomorrow um how will you indicate the
columns that we've approved will there
be some way you can indicate the columns
that we approved so I can highlight The
Columns that you've gone through and and
um considered yourself completed yeah um
and you would see that not only would
they be highlighted but the figures
would also be in there under the roow
for the house Ways and Means estimate
okay perfect um and then that would
leave or help you focus on those columns
that aren't um shaded so you know what
you have left to do y thank you
yep yes represent opal
um just a quick question I can't I'm not
sure whether I've forgotten or I I
missed one day so I wasn't here I am
assuming that the reason it is going
down from 25 to 26 to 27 is interest
that's correct okay yeah thank
you okay yeah so
um this is another one where I'm not
sure we have any information beyond what
has been presented to refute anything um
so uh column L other row 11 would be 1
15.5 No 1
15.5 we'll have a class in rounding
later of course I already made a mistake
rounding too so
round well we're rounding we're rounding
to no we're we're rounding to the
nearest
10th so that would have so it would have
to be 0 five 52 or something to go to 0.
five uh to go to0
6 so it's 1
15.5
um row 16 is 126.0
and row 21 is
120.0
maybe more or less um okay any um
it's motion on this
one you can second it
all in uh any
discussion seeing none all in favor
raise your
hand anyone opposed
no
okay represent El me i' just like to
point out before we leave this uh topic
that in
24 we
had aund we
had 30 3,00 uh million more than we got
in interest this would be probably uh in
we're going to get in 25 which is 24
more than we're going to get in 26 which
is six more than we're going to get in
so the total of those that we had
sitting around in interest
was more like
um
100 um no 60 60 million this since
24 I'm not sure I understand what's the
60 million um difference between
[Music]
183.2 in the draft CA uh cfer and uh 100
20 in 07 oh oh I should saying 60
million less okay
yeah okay any um oh no that's right
we're done with it we voted on that one
yeah we did okay um beer tax was pretty
straightforward changed in decades so
well it's changed this year so column K
beer Tech X row 11 test my rounding
abilities again
12.5 row 16 13.0 these are easy and uh
yeah 21
13.0 why do they think they're going to
get more
again I don't remember do you have a
anyone have a note on why it's up from
24 Chris do you don't have any I don't I
think the the trend up until this point
for this year just was showing a decline
on this is a revenue Source where
they've estimated 12 and a half to 13
million period annually because the
number of gallons of beer being sold
isn't changing it's the the types of
things that fall into the beer category
that is changing so you had um like
micro breweries that were took off for a
while those took away from your standard
alcoh uh beers like your Budweisers and
such more recently it's the the Blended
drinks that they're um seen arise in
people drinking that um and those don't
get taxed uh they do they they go they
go through um because of their alcohol
content they go through the beer
distributors and then they pay 30 cents
on the
Gown okay yeah represent you yeah I seem
to recall conversations with them I
forget whether it was here but the beer
buying population now that now that they
have the Blended
drinks that would replace the mixed
drinks like a mimosa at a diner isn't
made with
well that's a bad one because that is
made with champagne and beer and wine
licenses go together but uh one of the
other mixed breakfast drinks is now made
with a beer based product as opposed to
a liquor based product that they would
need another higher tier license so
you're increasing your sales because of
the anciliary products that are being
sold I that was one of the discussions
that was taking place because the
current
population tends to like
beer based stuff instead of alcohol
based stuff I don't know why I don't
recall them mentioning it in front of
the committee but they may have an yeah
I may had a moment where I zoned out
yeah I I put forward a be a bill to
change their tax and thing and they said
no we can do it without changing
anything if they buy and then they
started
marketing okay question yes thank you Mr
chairman so what what's the percentage
cut off again for where if falls in the
beers up below like
[Music]
8% I I would have to check that to
confirm I'm not positive it's okay yeah
I just remember but it's around that
it's around that this but I'd have to
confirm it yeah that's okay it's been
adjusted over the years and I just buy
what I can
buy thank you I remember something very
confusing uh about it's definitely 6%
for beer products and definitely 8% for
liquor products in the other direction
and then in between it's mixed how how
did they get to
that I can't answer that I have no idea
how you know how that was we have to ask
Commerce because nobody else really
reports to us about
beer
okay
un would someone like to make a motion
on these
numbers Mr move that we accept those
values for the numbers for beer tax on
lines 11 16 and 20 excuse me a second
I'll
second
discussion further discussion seeing
none Dr more
beer all in favor raise your
hand doesn't mean I any
opposed Mr CH I do have a question mhm
in order to better understand this don't
you think we ought to visit Budweiser
yes that could be a field trip yep I
think we did that years ago years
ago all right further one hell of
a further moving along to column J
general fund Securities Revenue excuse
me Mr chair before we move on uh
Shameless profit timeout my son owns a
brewery in Vermont so if anybody would
like to go for a tour sometime I'm sure
we'd get some free hats samples or
whatever so oh that's all right can you
can you move that can you move that
Brewery over to nire I have asked I
requested
that okay so column J Securities
Revenue
um column 11 13.6
column 7 uh 16
13.7 column 21
13.7 Mr chair I think you're off a row a
column oh sorry oh gee I just wrote them
all in too well we'll get
there let's do quick I like it I like it
let's do let's does next so that's
column I yes um court fines we're doing
court fines yep column I and go back
yeah
um so those those
are again I think that's pretty
straightforward it's pretty we agency uh
has
presented
umf
yeah
okay so just so I can make sure it's
going to be 136 on row 11 137 on row 16
and 137 on row 21
correct
um do I have a
second
second any discussion on column
I as
presented seeing none all in favor of
accepting what we just talked about
columi
representative
Spar okay any
oppose no
okay now we will go back to column J and
um I'll round those numbers column J row
44.3 row
16 column J 4 4.4 and
then row 21
44.5
motion who seconded
Okay discussion any discussion on this
um okay seeing no discussion let's vote
on it uh all in favor of accepting those
numbers for column
J raise your
hands okay anyone
opposed that was a wise vote you
made
5050 all right that was 15 to zero
um okay so I believe correct me if I'm
wrong Chris I think those are all the oh
no I see insurance tax oh good now
go okay um so
now um no wait a minute Communications
tax no no Communications tax will do
tomorrow um page three
column
F insurance
tax um okay I won't fill numbers in yet
because representative Aly wants to
debate so go
ahead well uh we have been hearing a lot
about catastrophic fires and
catastrophic uh
um Cyclones and things like that um and
how the whole nation is going going to
have to pay for the increased costs of
the insurance
agencies and
I when that has happened in the past a
number of people have dropped their
insurance they thought it was just too
high and they probably wouldn't have to
use
it and I don't have numbers
for for how much got affected in at
those times
but for instance when uh Katrina took
out New
Orleans um but we've we've had
catastrophic floods over twice three
times in
Vermont that the insurers had to pay for
and and all of most of California has
been been
if it's true that we can't just pass
that off on
California uh it's going to make
Insurance a lot more
expensive for all of
us yeah representative om yeah to follow
up on represent om's Point uh the impact
is Bel in New Hampshire because of the
reinsurance market yes so even though
the local insurance in California may be
in deep trouble
most of that is uh most of that hit is
taken by the broader country from the
reinsurance of these smaller companies
and so we are de
impacted
question thank you Mr chairman uh Chris
do we know if that's been considered in
these numbers because I've heard the
same thing so it's a it's a good point
needs to be
addressed I think what the commissioner
had um discussed with the committee is
that it's a
a national issue and is being worked on
currently but I don't know how well it's
reflected in what they're seeing here or
what you're seeing here sorry could we
check on that
please we
can and if I could add we used to have a
continuity in Insurance
Commissioners and I'm not sure I I know
that the person who is doing the most
work on this retired three years ago and
she helped out the first
year she was a wi but um I don't know to
what extent the current insurance
commission is is talking with other
Commissioners about what could be
happening
represent thank you Mr chairman as a
point of information the last time this
was brought up nationally
uh for uh the whole country to foot the
bill was right after Katrina and then
one Congressman uh woke up I don't know
which party it was and realized that
this was going to affect his State and
he spoke to everybody else and said why
are we going to protect private beach
owners and it got killed very fast in
Congress I don't think there's going to
be too much of a problem with that again
this year uh for saving California it's
like you won't cut your brush back you
won't do this and that to uh clean up
your forests uh that's what
happens and that that is ignoring the
reinsurance
market as representative M was
explaining uh all of these insurance
companies most of these insurance
companies maybe all of them um
reinsure for
guarantees they pay uh the the one in
London and we've got one here I think
New Hampshire Insurance new insurance
yeah on to insure them for their
losses and so when California has
enormous losses they they are coming to
their reinsurers
to get uh compensated and when they do
that then the reinsurers have to go and
put those costs on everybody else in
order to avoid
disappearing so represent Amy your point
is that if insurance rates are going to
go up then the insurance tax will will
go net will net more
yeah okay so I just more there were in
the past uh a fair number of people who
decided to go
naked no so then then that insurance
yeah that uh that was I think more in
health insurance but I'm not I'm not
sure I remember
correctly naked well it's probably
everything I mean if you can't afford
something you can't afford it um one of
the things I just did was I looked at uh
the number here uh oh actually I used
the wrong number I used 150 I was trying
to see what the percent change was from
2025 to
2026 actually it's a big
change yeah I they're going to increase
I used the high I used the high I should
have used the 143 let me just do a quick
calculation here so uh that's a 16
that's 16 over
143 16 /
143 that's uh 11.2 2% increase from 25
to 26 so I wonder if they're already
trying to take some of that into account
you look the the other thing that
affects our uh Property and Casualty
which is a large part of our insurance
uh is that uh the Senate and its wisdom
when we were uh working on insurance a
number of years ago
that we were going to uh make all when
we were doing expanded
medicaid on that we were going to tell
the insurance companies that they had to
this this medical insurance he
insurance they were going to have to pay
uh a year in advance
so in one year they paid two times what
they would I'm sorry put your microphone
on in one year they paid two times what
they should have paid had to pay and uh
no it was a six Monon difference so uh
they had to pay it again in six months
and then every year
thereafter um they get on they've been
on a on a seesaw where one one year they
get more money the next year they get
less money
doubled
uh
and and not knowing where they are in
that cycle at the moment makes it very
hard for us here to determine what's
actually they actually think is
happening but going up in a row each
time seems unusual
Mr chair so it's well I just want to
point out so the from
20 25 to 2026 as I said it was 11.2%
increase but from 26 to 27 it's only
about two and a half% increase um yeah
and the second year after there's been
an
increase in in the insurance tax to all
of those companies on they come back and
if they've made more money than the year
before uh then they have to make the
forward payment at Double that amount
that is increased then the next year if
things stabilize
back they have to they don't have to pay
more than half of of what on they can
reduce their their payments okay by that
amount it's really it's it makes it
incredibly difficult for us to calculate
yeah and it was because the Senate
didn't want us to have to pay pay up
front for six months and they arranged
to pay up
back
okay representative
Opel uh thank you Mr chair I I look I
think representative TIY is right about
Katrina and and the aftermath and that
but since then we've had you know other
devastating storms fires in California
the flooding and the completely
unprecedented impact of hurricanes in
the Carolinas including Asheville um I I
I think at least for me um and I
apologize again I think I missed the
insurance commissioner's original
presentation I I I think there's enough
uncertainty here that I I I would like
to ask this committee to invite the
insurance department back to maybe
address this specific issue before we
vote on a revenue estimate um there just
I think enough questions have been
raised certainly for me um that I'm not
sure I feel comfortable voting on these
numbers today without without getting
some more answers and and I'm sure Chris
you know representative or is ask ask
Chris to get the information I AB have
absolute faith that Chris could get that
information but I'd really kind of like
to hear it from the
Department
rone oh sorry rone shamber uh just in
regard to the numbers that are on here
uh we have in 26 A 159 and in 27 a 163
is that the insurance tax yet their
report shows 158 and 162 is that
a so if you're if you're looking at
their report yes just look at the line
above that you'll see that million
dollar reduction each year yep that
isn't in law yet that's a suggestion
that the department has put it so we add
that back in yep thank you and if if
other people are looking at that same
sheet just to go along with what ripson
Voli was saying if you follow from the
Top Line you got the premium tax
liability so that's what they collected
this year then you had the prepayment
that from the previous year which you
apply which is a negative number so
you'll see in I'll just use 26 they
assume 138.74503
that um idea of a prepayment that they
true up and then they get another
prepayment um so I don't know how that
truly they're able to look at the
national impact of some of what's being
discussed here when they're doing this
but I I think um I can either ask the
department the question or if the
committee wants them to come back we can
try to find a day with the chair to
bring them back
um representative Al me and then ORS
yeah I think if we all can find that
sheet that was the insurance
Department's um input or go to your
website where we'll find it and see the
zigzag that goes on in the the insurance
tax normally uh we still have the issue
of what's going to happen with the the
major increase in catastrophes this year
inside the United
States Representative boards thank you
Mr chairman so Chris and representative
of opal has a good point uh do you feel
that if you went back and ask the
Insurance Group whatever it is uh
whether or not their estimates are
accurate or they need to take another
look at them they give you an answer
what do you think are they going to be
able to are you going to trust their
answer oh that's kind of a loaded
question
yeah in other words go
ahead the answer is I'm going to trust
what they're reporting to because I
don't know better myself it's not not an
area that I'm have expertise in um but
what I I can get an answer to a question
I think the real question the committee
has is will that answer lead to other
questions that you would need the
department here to answer for you or
would you be satisfied with the answer
that I was able to provide that they
gave me yeah have well let me just yeah
so yeah I wasn't trying to set you up
obviously but I mean having done this
stuff on and off my whole life if you
will so I mean if I bring my if I went
and talk to my people and they get and I
said are these numbers still good and
they said yes I'd go with it if they
said no then I you know you should have
been talking to me already but okay
whatever you guys decide will'll be good
with me but thank you representative
erery I just a reminder to the committee
that uh these numbers are preliminary at
this point uh we're just beginning the
work uh and they will change in March
and April and May and
June uh because we're to spend at least
one maybe two days going over these
things again I would draw the
committee's attention to the uh official
plan which was 4 140 um I believe wasn't
it yep and then the uh preliminaries are
163 which is a plus
23 the 163 was a combination of factors
in increase cost of each of our
individual policies uh be it auto
insurance or health insurance or home
insurance well of all of our
insurances and inflation and the value
apportionment of certain of our vehicles
and homes um so that's one reason that
that took place um The increased plan
for the other ones are mod are large but
there are modest
increases related to the initial bump
that took place last fiscal year or this
fiscal year
still so I'm not worried about the
numbers right now we will have a chance
to look at them I don't think we need
another uh thing to come in I think we
start with these numbers and then we
take a look at what's going on as far as
the reinsurance in New Hampshire there
was once a very large ational insurance
company called New Hampshire Insurance
Group which was bought out by AIG AIG is
I believe Swiss group now and it's
International so this recent storm that
just hit Northern England or northern
Europe we're going to be paying perhaps
pennies perhaps a dollar uh of that cost
because the way insurance has always
been set up ever since they started
started serving tea at Lloyd's tea house
um that's how it works good
explanation I would like to see some
evidence that they are uh Consulting the
National
Insurance uh Association or whatever
it's
called about uh how
much they think that is going to impact
us that's fine the commissioner did say
that the all the insurance Commissioners
from around the state are part of that
organization and that meet on a regular
basis to discuss issues and try to um
normalize I guess is the word I'll use
I'm not sure if it's the right word but
to try to have some similarities in the
way that insurance is run in each state
not to say it's exactly the same but to
make it a little bit easier for some of
the insurance providers to go from state
to state so there is that I don't know
if that specific question has been
discussed I would assume yes but I can
ask the department for sure yeah
thanks yeah representative ulry yeah
just to follow up on that New Hampshire
also participates in a little known
unpublicized group of uh law compliance
that uh tries to make the laws conform
one to another in each state um and we
part of it it's about five people that
are all got initials after their names
for some reason and no one knows what
they do but they make sure that it
works all right you know I I yeah that
was quite an explanation you
gave and Jordan yeah that was quite an
explanation you I hate to have you know
I hate to have to agree with you I I
just want to go on
record all right so um um Chris you're
going to check with the insurance
department to see um are they
comfortable with these numbers and did
they take into account or take into
account or do do the latest events in
California for
instance affect us um my my guess is
that my guess is they've they've this is
what they do I'm sure they've they've
looked at it but we'll we'll hold off on
voting for this hopefully um you know we
get an
answer
um
soon uh question what happened in
Ashville Asheville oh Asheville thought
you
said no it's ribs in Nashville Furniture
in
Asheville it's all over
that
yeah and it's not a PR I me
okay let's um getting close to three
o'clock let's try to finish up here we
have one more one more column to look at
right now and that's column D liquor
transfer and um so column
D line 11
101.7 um column uh I'm sorry row 16
102.9 and row 21 102. three and
representative jewelry yeah I think the
agency's numbers in this case uh their
General history after the Reformation of
uh 20 what was that 10 9 10 when we
changed it the board structure and
everything else they've been
real very very accurate uh regarding
their numbers and their projections of
their Market they now have a marketing
team on board that uh looks at the in
economy and figures out how much we can
squeeze out of anyone who wants to buy
something well somebody want to make a
motion on accepting these representative
tney and Al me
seconds um any further discussion on
these numbers on under column D liquor
transfer seeing yes represent El me
wanted to check this is after all the
things that the legis keeps
Al it it is it's the uh the net number
so they they've tried to adjust for the
transfer to the governor's alcohol
commission fund as well as the money
that goes to granted Advantage which is
the Medicaid expansion fund um there is
always the opportunity for Department of
Health and Human Services to come
forward and ask for More Liquor funds
because that's the way the statute is
written um but they didn't anticipate
any more than what they've accounted
for okay anybody
else all right seeing n all in favor
accepting uh liquor transfer as we just
discussed any opposed seeing none 15 to
zero um okay so I think let's take a
quick look I think that concludes so um
tomorrow we will not necessarily we'll
see how much progress we make but we are
working on this
uh from in the morning roughly 10 to 12
and then um in the afternoon say roughly
1 to two to three somewhere in there and
then we're executing four bills I put in
the calendar as you probably notice 2
o'clock just in case we get to a point
where we feel like you know we're we're
done and I didn't want to have to wait
till 3 just to exec things I would um so
basically as I look at this let's see
column so we what we have left is total
business taxes rooms and meals
tobacco well interest in dividends I
guess that will be oh that's that's
really a difficult one that's um that's
fairly
straightforward well we'll do that
tomorrow when Chris has that filled in
because we did get some numbers today uh
Communications tax real estate
transfer um
what no we did courts findes and
fees Lottery we did Lottery and then the
last one would be utility property tax
we already did we did Highway and we did
fishing okay
good anybody have uh any
questions just one quick comment on the
interest in dividends um the
commissioner gave you the 25 number at
1343 so that's the number you won't see
a high low for interest in dividends
you'll see
134.5 for both the high and the low
number oh her document has a um a high
and a low range but when she was
testifying in front of you today with
her presentation she said that 25 will
be
134.5 and then you would reduce um down
to
8.7 in 26 and 0 and
27 okay well so I just I'm going to put
it that's how I'm going to reflect it
I'm not a suggesting do anything with it
today yeah okay sounds good all right
that's it for today then thank you
everyone we'll see you tomorrow 10 o'
say
I we we're
jour e